Bikes
with them.
All right?
People were alive on the Youtube and I've
got the sage of the alt right without
the rain, without the rage. Payroll Age,
without the rate of the Ri. Ben Shapiro,
welcome back as gun. All right, we've
got a lot of things to talk about.
I want to cover a ton of new ground.
I read your book over the weekend.
You have a new Prager u video going up.
You're still doing this daily wire
thing and a thousand other things.
So we got a lot to do here, but let,
let's just start with this. All right,
nonsense. Um, I hate that we even have to
talk about it. It's so freaking stupid,
but this happens to be the world
that we live in at the moment.
So about two weeks ago or
about 10 days ago or so, uh,
the economists did an interview with you.
Uh,
I assume that was by the phone
probably originally. Yeah.
So you did a phone interview with
them and they, they're really nice.
The interview, by the way, I get
a yes, you read the transcript.
It's perfectly nice. A little bit
adversarial, but that's good. That's fine.
They usually are Shapiro.
That's how it works. Right?
Like the interviews themselves and the
thoughts usually stand on their own.
Anyway. They, they published this
interview and what was the title?
It was called the [inaudible] Shapiro.
The outright sage without the rage,
which is wrong.
Then at least a couple of scores.
Any half the media tries to portray you
as if you've got this evil rage within
you all the time.
But I thought that was funny on it,
which is weird cause you met me and him.
I'm fairly calm.
This is really all the time. This is about
as rage as it gets right here. Yeah. So,
okay, let's put aside the
rage part. The Ot right.
Parked and just what the media
is constantly doing. So, okay.
So after you publicly then shame them
forward and everybody jumped on board to,
to defend you. Um, and you know,
all these things got thousands
and thousands of retweets.
Eventually they did a printer retraction.
They apologized.
They apologized and they,
you know,
they appreciate [inaudible] where
basically they just said, oh,
he's not part of the alt right,
and it's like, well, what
just happened here? Right.
You guys just said he's the sage of the,
all right.
There's this thing called
the Google machine. Yeah.
If they had just typed in
my name with all right,
they would have seen probably the
first result is a piece I wrote for The
Washington Post in 2015 talking about
how evil the alt right as if they,
I mean it was a review of the book.
I mean in the book which you have read,
I referenced the alt right I think three
or four separate times and talk about
how terrible their ideas are
and how evil their ideology is.
No white supremacy is gross.
The whole point of the book is that
you're trying to show people the clean way
to think there was sort of right way
to think so that you don't fall prey
correct to those things.
Then Western civilization
is not built on race.
Western civilization is built
on certain immutable principles.
That's the basis of the book.
It's the basis of conservatism
to a more classical liberalism.
I mean all of this is
built on the same idea,
which is that this stuff is not
relegated to race. Like I'm a Jew. Okay.
The Jews weren't part of that
original white people bargain.
If there was a white people bargain and
you're Jewish too. I mean like come on.
I mean this is all, it's all
bullshit but it's it. But,
and I've done open battle with the alt
right for legitimately years. I mean
I always cite the statutes because
it's a useful step, but it's true.
I mean I was attacking more than than
any other Jewish journalists on the line
in 2016 the vast majority of
that crap was from the alt right.
The alt right still hates my guts.
I have to have significant security
around me nearly all times because of the
number of threats we get
from people on the alt right.
And I'm being called out
right by the economist,
which is supposed to be a center right.
Magazine in Europe.
Is that, that I think is the
question. It's like everyone gets it.
This is what the media does. They don't
mind. They lie, they label, they smear,
all of those things. Everyone
understands that. But what is it?
The economist is basically a respectable
as you can center right magazine this,
these are people who you would think
ideologically basically line up with you.
So what do you think is
truly going on there?
Is it purely just the quest for clicks
put Shapiro's picture? I put, all right,
all hell is going to bring it up.
I'm wondering, so what is it
I tend to hold by, you know,
the Hanlon's razor idea that it's mostly
ignorance and not malice and I think
for some of these people it is ignorance.
I think that for the economist then they
apologized within a couple of hours.
I think it legitimately was,
there was somebody writing and headline
who doesn't know what the alt right is.
They don't know the difference between
the outright and conservatism in the
United States and in Europe.
The alt right is a lot closer
to European right wing populism.
Then the alright is to American
conservatism and a lot of ways,
and so I think they just figure
anybody who's anti-left is all right.
I mean they've labeled Jordan outright,
they've labeled you outright right now,
like not the economist, but a lot of
people in the media will do this routine.
They'll, they'll say that the
IDW generally is all right.
I believe I'm the only registered
Republican as far as I'm aware in the,
in the IDW, it's absurd. People that
voted for Bernie. Yeah, exactly.
The more people who voted for Bernie
than voted for Trump among members of the
IDW, I think that's fair to
say. Correct. I'm pretty sure
that's true, right? I mean,
I think Brett voted for Bernie. I
think that Eric voted for Bernie. Uh,
I know that, uh, Sam voted
for Hillary like that.
There are many more members
of the political life voted
for Gary Johnson. Right.
You voted for Gary Johnson Ford.
I didn't vote.
I didn't vote at all in the 2016
election at the top of the ticket.
So I'm not sure if there was one
person who voted for Trump in the IDW,
but we become outright because if
you're a heterodox thinker or if you're
somebody who asks questions and
then comes up with with answers that
specifically are designed
to reject the outright,
then you are suddenly a member of the
outright just by taking the questions
seriously. And this is part of
that's really dangerous, right?
You see this with Steven Pinker, I think
this is the best example that I saw.
You remember Steven pinker gave the
speech a few years back where he said,
you know,
the problem with the rise of the alt
right is that there are a bunch of people
on the left are rejecting the question
and then they refused to give an answer
to the question.
And so people go looking for the answer
and the only answer they get is the
worst answer. He wasn't defending
the Ansi rats the point,
the whole point of his speech was no.
We need to give the correct answers that
people don't fall prey to the stupid
crap that's being said about race and Iq,
for example.
But we can't ignore the questions about
race and Iq because otherwise people are
still going to look for the
answers to these questions.
And what he's saying is effectively the
same thing that people in the religious
community are constantly saying about,
you know,
you see people who go to Sunday
school and then it's like, well,
I asked all my questions and the
rabbi or the pastor or the priest,
they all said, you know, you're
not allowed to ask those questions.
And so I left the religion.
That's what pinker is saying about logic
and reason in western civilized ideas
that people came in and they ask these
questions and instead of the questions
being answered, people like, you're
not allowed to ask that question.
It's a very bad question. And you saw
vodkas did this too to Sam Harris, right?
When Sam was talking about race and Iq.
And when people say that,
when people ask about whether Islam
has a problem with violence right then,
then this is considered
an outright perspective.
And so they'll band Jordan's
book in Christ church from,
from with Kohl's briefly based on the
idea that Jordan has suggested that
Islamophobia is an overused term and
is misapplied. Right. That that's,
that's also took that picture
with the guy in the shirt,
the human with the human,
and you've done many of these and
I've been on tour with Jordan.
He said he's been taking pictures
with about 30,000 people that, yeah,
I would imagine that's a low estimate.
Probably been there where he's had
lines of hundreds of people course after
giving a two hour lecture after
doing 10 interviews during the day,
after flying into the city that morning.
The idea that he's investigating what
everyone's wearing or that anyone is
paying any attention to that,
the,
I forget what you think about
what it would sell it unless,
unless the shirt legitimately as a
giant swastika or giant hammer sickle or
something like people are
milled through every 10 seconds.
I mean those generally come up, they
take the picture, they shake your hand,
they leave. I mean, you guys have
done tens of thousands of pictures.
I've done tens of thousands. I don't
remember any of the pictures that I took.
I mean legitimately I remember the idea
was that he took a picture with this guy.
Now we're going to,
right now we're going to ban his book
because then the Cambridge thing,
which is even worse, right?
That that that was even worse,
but I mean even in the New
Zealand thing where the,
the notion that you are going to be
able to crack down on white supremacy by
banning speech generally is so dangerous.
And listen,
if white supremacy will crack down on,
I'd be one of the chief beneficiaries
of the crackdowns since,
I mean they hate me. Right. We'll set it.
I sat on rogue and I'm
not going to do it again.
I'm being really careful about my
f word. Use it. We have one of the,
I mean as you know,
because we're friends,
one of the bizarre things is how little
I on camera and how much I crossed off
camera. That's a lot of f bombs
off a lot of f bombs off camera.
But good morning then go fucking
mornings and erect. Exactly. But it's,
but that mean New Zealand legitimately
is now going to prosecute people who
downloaded the manifesto for
the white supremacist. And
I thought to myself, well,
I downloaded it because I wanted to read
what was in there so that I knew how to
rebut it. I mean, the solution to this
stuff is not to crack down on speech.
It was really scary. All right, so
there's so much I want to do here.
So just let's go with that for a second.
So in a case of what
happened in Christ church,
do you think actually that reading
it does add value? Because I get,
you want to understand it a little bit,
at least the people that are talking
about, right, but in another way,
it doesn't adjust,
incentivize other people to do crazy
things because that it's like, Holy Shit,
Ben Shapiro, all these,
all these Internet people,
they're going to read what I said,
even if it's complete insanity.
And this thing had conflicting, I openly
said, don't mention the guy's name. Don't,
don't repeat his,
his ideas don't guys never publicly,
we don't publish names of
shooters. We won't do it. I,
and I even instructed our people like
only report on the manifesto to the extent
necessary to knock down myths about the
manifesto. And that was the big problem.
The reason that I downloaded it was not
because I originally wanted to read what
the guy said because you don't
want to give that credence.
It's because the media started immediately
misreporting what the guy had said
and effectively doing exactly
what he told them to do,
which is report on everything that I say.
So to so as to divide people and then
the division itself will create more
polarization in society,
which is what I want.
I mean he says this in the manifesto and,
and the, and the media were like, yeah,
let's, let's do that
thing, which is, you know,
it's interesting which manifestos they
choose to report on and which ones become
irrelevant nearly as soon
as they are released. I mean
other show really and how
they decide what is relevant.
But I will say regardless of what, like
I don't think it should be distributed.
I don't think people should read it.
But if you do pick it up and read it,
I don't think that you should
be arrested for that. I mean,
criminalizing people who downloaded
a file seems to me really,
really dangerous stuff because you can
link virtually anything. I mean they,
again, they tried to ban the bestselling
book on planet Earth from the biggest
bookseller in New Zealand because Jordan
was in a picture with a human like,
I don't trust, I don't trust
anybody to regulate speech that way.
Or were they looking to arrest people
that shared the video also? Yeah,
they're doing that too.
And now they're saying they want to
hold members of social media hierarchies
personally responsible for
distribution of bad material.
This is one of the things that are pushing
in in the UK is that they're trying
to regulate social media to the extent
that they could haul Zuckerberg in the
court.
And Jaylen,
if certain controversial material
is distributed via via Facebook.
I mean this is not,
it's UNAMERICAN is the easy way to say it,
but it's not on European I guess.
Do you think that's why he's Zuckerberg?
Just in the last week has sort of been
hinting off like regulate me please.
They actually want
regulation now. Well, yeah,
I think that what's happening
for Zuckerberg will get
them off the hook. Right,
exactly. It's a couple
of things. One is the,
he's hoping for regulation from the
United States government because he knows
he's going to get regulated
from the Europeans.
And what he is afraid of is being stuck
in this catch 22 where the Europeans
regulate him on speech.
And then for business reasons,
he starts using those regulations as the
basis for policing stuff in the United
States. And then people in
the United States say, well,
you're policing and policing is not even,
and so you're actually an editorial outlet
now and you should be treated like an
editorial outlet as opposed
to like arguments for that
or I think they should be,
they should do it for,
for a long time.
I think they should be treated like an
editorial outlet if they're going to act
like an editorial outlet. Um, but he,
he stuck sort of between
a rock and a hard place.
Whenever you see a business
that is calling for additional
regulation on itself,
you can fairly guarantee that this is
a corporatist attempt to crowd other
people out of the market
and to avoid responsibility.
And it seems to me that that's mainly
what's happening here. All right,
so let's back up for a second.
So after the Christchurch attack,
blue check, Twitter went
completely bananas on you. On me,
on several other people, Sam Jordan,
everybody. Well, it's fun on Sam.
Um, none of us have ever called
for violence obviously. Of course,
single one of us have no
problem condemning this.
Want these things to be stopped or I can
see the glossed over and look in your
eyes as I'm saying it, it's,
it's, it's securing and
boring to have to say it.
Um,
what do you think our
responsibility or our,
our duty to respond to some of this is?
Because it seems to me it's getting
haywire, the people that when someone,
when 50 people are killed in a horrific
attack halfway across the world,
when that happens, and then blue check
journalists directly blame you. Let's say,
let's just keep this on you for a second.
It seems to me they're putting more of
a price tag on your head or a more of a
direct threat on your head.
Then anything that you have ever said.
I mean, I think that's true. I think
there's not much I can do about it.
I mean it there,
there's certain material that obviously
is libelous and theoretically you could
take legal action,
but I'm a public figure.
That means I'm going to take plenty of
slings and arrows and that's fine. I mean,
that's,
that's part of the debate.
I'm the one advocating that we should be
able to speak about this stuff as much
as you want to.
It's one thing for the economist to label
me a label that is clearly not true.
It's another thing for people to draw the
attenuated sort of connection between.
I've criticized Islams violent tendencies
across the world without saying that
every Muslim is violent or,
and certainly not saying that any
Muslims should be treated with violence.
I mean, I've never sent any
of that stuff. But if you want
Jewish theologians and
Catholic theologians,
Christian theologians have been arguing
about what's in the Bible and what it
all means. And all of those
things specifically be insane.
I specifically say, and I've been saying
this for as long as I can remember,
I do not analyze the Quran.
I do not analyze the religion of Islam
because you can go through the religious
tax of virtually any religion,
including my own,
and find stuff that is deeply
uncomfortable and ugly.
And that's why I believe in a
reinterpreted structure. I mean,
I talk about that in the book and we'll
get to that, I'm sure, but it's, but the,
but the fact is that the balance between
reason and revelation is very key to my
thinking. And so I don't look at the Quran
and go looking for versus to take the,
I'm not an Islamic scholar.
There are many people who are there,
they're moderate and reform Muslims.
So I've had routinely on my radio
show to try and talk about the
reinterpretation of Islam. They're much
better situated to do that than I am.
All I can do is point
out that by polling data,
there are a lot of Muslims across the
world who believes some really radical
things that if any Christian believed
them, the media would immediately say,
this person is a radical
Christian by any definition.
So I point that out and suddenly it's,
I'm saying that what now I'm just,
I'm calling for violence against people
quite don't know. So who do I don't,
I don't know what they, not only,
I don't know what they think,
but they're allowed to think
whatever the hell they want.
You can think what you want without
being subjected to violence.
I don't know how they act. I don't
know any of that stuff. I mean,
it's its absurdity on its face,
and yet the attempt is of course,
to be, I mean, you and
you saw the media do this,
they immediately shifted from what
happened in Christchurch is the result of
people who are critical, particularly of
Ilhan. Omar, you actually saw this, right?
There's this move to say, well, if
you call Ilhan Omar an antisemite,
then you're contributing to just the
kind of Islamophobia that lead's what
happened in Christ. It's
like, wait, hold on a second.
I defended Ilhan Omar being able to
wear he job on the, on the house floor.
I think that's a good thing. I wear
a funny hat all day long, right?
Like that's fine with me. I
don't care. I think that's good.
I W I came out originally against Trump's
originally formulated Muslim ban when
he was like, yeah, no Muslims
coming in. I said, this is,
this is counterproductive and,
and it's intolerant, right?
I said all of those things because
those are true, and then it was,
but if you critique the fact that
Ohana is clearly antisemitic,
then you are leading like this is an
attempt to curve out a to it to carve out
speech,
right?
It's an attempt to say you're not allowed
to criticize x because we don't like
you criticizing acts, and if we can
blame this thing over here on you,
then that allows us to silence
you on this particular issue.
So what tactic may be or some of us
missing to clean some of this up because I
agree that basically what's
happening here is there,
there is these people
have been incentivized for
anytime anything bad happens,
you blame a few people
that have some influence.
So let's say you blame Peterson and you
and a couple of other people because
it's like,
oh,
you guys are helping wake up people to
their own thoughts and to how to live
their own lives by their own volition and,
and all the things that are in this book.
So there is every reason to
attack you because this is what
slept.
And it's also,
and it's also an easy game because the
fact is whoever has been very productive
in the public sphere, I'm sure has said
things that they don't like. Yeah, I mean,
I like this.
I keep referring to it because it's true.
I have a running list of crap
that I've said over the past.
I've been doing this since I was 17 years
old and now 35 so more than half of my
life, I have been doing this. I've
written legitimately millions of voters,
can't remember everything I wrote.
I've written a column a week
since I was 17 years old. Right?
I've written legitimately thousands of
columns at this point and I was writing
like eight pieces a day when I was at
Breitbart and I was writing for pieces a
day for daily wire for years on end.
I don't remember everything.
I remember I had 140,000 tweets.
I remember everything that I've tweeted.
So if somebody points something out
to me, I'm like, yeah, that was bad.
Then I'm just, I'm happy
to say, yeah, that was bad.
[inaudible] you wrote
a piece for daily wire,
the rest here basic and I update it,
I do update it will remind me and
they'll be like, yeah, this is a bad too.
I'm like, you're right.
That was a bad tweet.
I did it back in 2008 and it was a dumb
thing to do and I'm sorry that that
happened. It's like, I don't remember
all that stuff, but uh, but it's,
it's really a bad faith attempt to
take down people who are not like,
this is what Tucker Carlson rightly
pointed out when people were coming after
him. This was not an attempt to
make the public space battery.
It was not an attempt to wipe out bad
speech that was happening in the here and
now because we don't have a time machine,
right?
We can call up stuff from 15 years ago
like they're digging up interviews from
John Wayne has been dead for 40 years.
It's like,
well I don't know what you want
from John Wayne. Dude's dead right?
We can't take up a skeleton
and asking for an apology.
If I say something now
that you don't like,
then we can have a debate over that thing.
But if you are digging up
something I said 15 years ago,
all I can do is either say I disagree
with me from back then or I agree with,
and then we can have a discussion
about what I think now. But I can't,
like I don't have a time machine. So
this is all bad faith, uh, and it's,
and it's really pretty hideous.
It's one thing to dig up something
somebody has said in the past and then say
this fits in with their
generalized worldview, right.
But to take something out
of context and then say,
ignore all contrary evidence
and then just say, well,
this is the world view because I want
this to be the worldview so I can suggest
that they're outside the Overton window
and we don't have to deal with them
anymore. That's, that's how glean
that's, that's what's happening. I mean,
even though there's this video that was
going around and it got a bunch of heads
from some lefty who had taken,
legitimately taken,
I mean openly taken stuff out of context.
Yeah.
And put it into video to suggest that I
was calling for the murder of Muslims.
And it is a lie. It is a full on
full stop. Absolute bullshit lie.
I mean he took,
he took a section from an asteroid that
I do for a second amendment group called
the u s concealed carry association in
which I say that citizens should be law
abiding,
citizens should be armed and they should
have concealed carry permits because if
you are going to be victimized by a crime,
the government can't stop that so you
should be able to defend yourself.
He took the part where I say
the government can't stop
this and connected it to
my video about how many radical Muslims
that are on earth and then suggested
that what I was saying is that you
should arm up and go kill Muslims because
there are a lot of violent
thinking Muslims on earth
or extreme Muslims on earth
that now I'm suggesting that you should
preemptively take action because the
government can't protect you. I mean he
was legitimately taking too disconnected.
Thoughts on two separate topics,
cobbling them together and then
suggesting that was my position.
It was just an open line. Was this a
public person? Is this, or, oh yeah,
I know this is a public person than
actual roof. Is it human? Yeah,
this is a human. So what do you
do with a case like that? Okay,
you can defend yourself on
yet we've all done this,
but I'm starting to think that that's
not enough. And it's an odd place.
And I had Robert Barnes here are a couple
of weeks for the lawyer and it's like,
it's an odd place for the
free speech guys to be going.
We have to figure out what are the legal
protections around speech because it's
so not. And I, and I hate it, like in
the worst position for me to possibly be.
Right. And yet here we are. I mean
you just defending herself. Well,
the guy's just going to keep doing it. You
get him clicks. Congratulations. Right?
And that, that is what it is. You know,
I'm loathe to either change libel or
defamation laws in the United States.
I prefer that people say
more rather than less.
I think most people see through this
nonsense. And I if I didn't think that,
that we couldn't really have republic
is the truth. But it's, but yeah,
I mean it's, it's obviously deeply
to serving and as a good person,
the first thing that happens, you know,
if you're trying to be good, like I'm,
I don't think, I think I'm a person
who trying to be a good person.
And I think most people who are trying to
be good people, when you are critiqued,
the first thing you think
is, okay, is that true?
And your first instinct is
did I do something wrong?
And then the more you think about it,
like, no, I didn't. This is just bullshit.
So I mean other than just
calling it out when it occurs,
I'm not sure what else people can do.
And even giving an air time is a problem
because then it just drives them to
double down in response and then
suggest, no, no, no. Now he's lying.
Now he's lying because they,
they want to read into what they,
what they want to read in.
You can't have a good faith discussion
this way and it's not meant to be a good
faith discussion.
How much do you think is just they want
to take you out versus just they want to
scare everybody else?
Like it's pretty clear to me they're
not going to take you out out of fear.
Right? They're not going, I mean, I think
that it's, it's two. It's two things. One,
there's always the pipe dream
that there'll be able to
take somebody like me out,
but I think that it's
about more than that.
It's about making sure that people who
are considered inside the Overton window
won't even have a conversation
with people like me.
So Andrew Yang comes on my Sunday
special and it's great. I mean,
it's a really tolerant civil conversation.
I took his ideas seriously.
I read his book, I let him speak his
piece. It was really nice, very nice guy.
I've invited every major
democratic candidate and on
a judge had suggested that
he was going to come out at one point
and then he just never has responded yet.
I'd love to have them on
and ask him some questions and it would
be very civil because the Sunday special
is a very civil place. Uh, and that's,
he got Yang has gotten excoriated by the
left for even coming on the show, right?
Joe Rogan has me on his show and he gets
hit by the left with you're having on
that white supremacists, Shapiro, you're
going to get hit just for having me on.
That's the way this works. Because if
they can alienate enough people by saying,
okay, well we can't give them,
if we can d platform everybody,
then it's an easy way of avoiding
actually having to regulate.
What you do is you just make a deeply
uncomfortable and so we sort of, you know,
do I really want the flack of having on x,
Y or z if that over to the window,
I guess I've got to go this way.
You keep moving it left right to the point
that any that everybody is outside of
it and the truth is that that's an
effective tech specifically because there
isn't Overton window.
I mean it does exist.
There are people I wouldn't
have on my Sunday special.
There are people who I wouldn't,
I wouldn't appear with. Yeah,
I mean I've said that before. And so
because that's a little murkier of a line,
it's easier to manipulate that
line. It's easier to say, okay,
well since we all accept that
there is this Overton window,
then we can use that Overton window
and shift the line here and there.
Now it's interesting that the Overton
window is constantly shifting, as you say,
left in every direction.
Meaning that you can express the wildest,
most insane views on the left and still
be considered well inside the Overton
window.
And if you are as Heterodox as Sam Harris,
a Hillary Clinton supporter who has
said a couple of heterodox things like I
like, I want to look at the evidence on
Iq and then analyze how much of that is
environmental and how
much of that is genetic.
And I want to look at how much
that affects disparities overall.
Or I'm saying that Islam
has a relationship with
violence globally speaking.
Those heterodox opinions mean they're,
I mean they're,
they'll rule out Sam before they
rule out Maxine waters, right?
That's the way that this works.
So they'll rule out anybody,
Christina Hoff summers is too
far right for them. She's,
she's a white supremacist now,
but they'll keep expanding that all the
way to the point where anybody's wild
opinion is acceptable.
Like the right is routinely throwing
people out for expressing opinions that we
find unpleasant outside of our
norm. Right. When Steve King came,
finally said kind of openly,
the white nationalists comment to the
New York Times, we throw them out.
I mean we took away as committee
assignments and I donated the Max to his
opponent. I raised money for Kevin
[inaudible] who's running in his district.
Right.
And,
and the left's response was why was he
even a part of you wants took a picture.
I took a picture with him right before
he said any before he said that stuff
that was open. Right, exactly. And
so that's what it becomes is well,
were you once nice to this person?
And it's like, well that was before.
And also you guys are roots like Louis
Farrakhan is still a person who meets
with members of the Democratic Caucus.
Like what, what, why is it the,
the window only shifts in one direction.
I'm not going to listen to people who
tell me about who should be inside the
Overton window when they legitimately
refuse to throw anyone outside the Overton
window,
no matter how vile they are.
Ilhan Omar just got defended by the entire
Democratic Congress after saying for
three antisemitic things in the
course of seven weeks. Right?
She was defended by the Democratic
Caucus and left with our position on the
foreign affairs committee
because they're, they're afraid that their
own tactics will be used against them.
So I would imagine in
Biden's getting it now,
I mean I've been calling this river and
it eventually will happen to Bernie to,
it has to happen. That's,
that's the nature of the beast.
How much of this though
do you think is that bike?
Cause I see this now cause I get a lot
of former former lefties, let's say, uh,
even some who've been on
this show who publicly,
they're like this thing the left
is just burned. We get what it is.
But publicly they won't say that they've
shifted or that they're evolving or
that if you're an old school liberal you,
you can actually be okay with a lot
of conservative ideas are conservative
people because there's
a protection involved.
If you're basically a
democrat or on the left,
Joe Biden can run around with a gazillion
videos of sniffing girl's hair and
grabbing people in all of that.
And yet the people that were
going crazy over cabinet,
I have nothing to say about that,
that there's just a protection.
You get as a lefty that you
simply don't get and it's,
and it's comfortable not to raise your
head above the water line. I mean I like,
I like tell the story
of that on my birthday.
So I have a lot of a lot of friends in
the media or people find friendly with,
I wouldn't call them
friends because of this,
not because of the people
who I am acquainted.
Question is would they
consider you a friend?
That really is the question
because it's my birthday, right?
I routinely wish people,
I disagree with happy birthday online.
It seems like a basic thing of courtesies.
It's,
it's someone's birthday there on
the left, fine, it's your birthday.
Happy Birthday. People will text
me on the left happy birthday.
I can't do this publicly.
They will not tweet happy birthday
because they are afraid that if they tweet
happy birthday, they have then given
me the credence of I was born in,
therefore I'm a human being and they're
going to get hit with how dare you wish
this terrible person, this,
this orthodox Jewish neo Nazi.
How dare you wish that person
happy birthday, right? The the,
the effect of being duped.
Lost is a thing.
I mean the d the d plus thing I
thought was so telling and it was so,
and everybody knew gut level that if you
said that a person on the other side is
a human being that you got hit. But it's
funny, I don't get this from the right,
meaning that I say Andrew
Yang is a human right.
He's running for the 2020 nomination.
I treated him really well and things,
an intelligent guy.
I think he's a nice guy.
I've said about buddy checks I've never
met. He seems like a nice person. Like I,
I, I will say that about the vast majority
of people who I disagree with on the
left and they're nice
people who I disagree with.
There's some more badly motivated
and those people I tried to avoid,
but the vast majority of them are like
people you'd want to hang out with and
seemed like nice people he
can have a conversation with.
When is the last time somebody has ever
said that about somebody on the right
there a nice PR by Joe Biden. You
Recall? This actually happened to Biden.
So Biden said this about pence, right?
He said pence was a nice person. Yeah.
And then Biden got hit so hard that he
backed off of it and he was like, well,
you know what? No one can hold
the beliefs that Mike pence can.
It has and still be a nice person then.
I'm sorry we can't have a politics.
If the idea is that we
are that you are my enemy,
then we are no longer even operating in
the same sphere than my politics make me
evil.
But your politics make you a nice person.
How am I supposed to have a
conversation with you on that basis?
So do you think then that Biden is
the last chance for any Democrat to be
somewhat centrist or decent for all the
disagreements you may have with Biden?
I mean,
even
the last one I think is seen
not only with the pen thing,
but he had to dealt double down with
a whole bunch of something as Politics
Hillary yet. But he's on
the apology tour. But,
but when you see how radical the
Democrats have gone, and again,
this is like everything I was
fighting against for all these years,
you know what I mean?
Yeah. This was like, guys,
this is going to happen if we
don't start fixing it right now.
I don't even think it's my
job to fix anymore. Right.
It has to just sort of burn.
It's just, it just is.
That's a very unfortunate,
because I think as Jordan would say,
you need a certain tension between the
right and the left. It's as equal tension,
let's say. Um, but do you think
Biden's like the last chance for that,
for anything that's sort of,
I think the carver school democrats.
Yeah. Carving out his soul right now.
And so we'll see where he stands by the,
I mean they'd taken basically an ice
cream scoop and gone through his innards
with this.
And I just,
I don't know how much in Biden is
going to be left at the end of this.
I think Biden's initial instinct,
and I really don't like Joe Biden as a
politician. I think he fibbed a lot. I,
I don't like his policies,
but I think his initial instinct before
he gets political is that he can talk
with people on the other side
of the beltway was friends
with McCain cane for so
many years in all of this.
I think that this is being beat
out of him in the primaries. Yeah.
Because it's just unacceptable. I was
hoping the same thing was true about,
about Buddha judge, right. I was,
I was hoping the Buddhist said
she was going to be that right.
He said something like, you know, I
don't like the position of Dan Cathy,
the head of chick fil a, but they
make good chicken, so I'll eat there.
And I was like, well that's refreshing.
Isn't that a nice thing like radical.
I know,
but that was the,
that was the only moderate thing I've
heard in the entire Democratic primary and
now booty, Trisha switching. And
it's, again, Mike pens hates me,
my pencils out to get me
because he's a bad guy.
And if Mike Pence thinks
that I'm a bad person,
what he's really doing is he's rejecting
God because God made me the way that I
am. It's like whatever. Mike Pence,
his views on the sinfulness
of homosexual activity,
Mike pence has treated
booty guys really well.
I mean there's a bunch of records of him
like when Buddhist edge was activated
in the military,
pence personally called him up to
wish him best of luck in all of that.
Like he's never said a bad word about
Buddhist Asia. As far as I'm aware,
our friend Rick Grinnell,
who's the ambassador to Germany who's gay,
the right has only good things
to say about Mike Pence.
I'm not saying that everything Mike
Pence says or believes would line up with
everything.
I believe.
Of course Trump has also been president
for two plus years or they come in for
the gays, right? It's
a, you bring anyone with
beautiful. Then the fact that [inaudible]
has to make up a fake Mike Pence. Yeah,
right. Where we're pens is now his
enemy and out to get him is just,
it's really telling about the,
the polarization of politics
and the attempt to shift
political differences into
character assassination.
This idea that pence disagrees with me
about same sex marriage and therefore he
actually hates me and it's like,
well,
you have no evidence whatsoever
that that is the case.
Like you're allowed to hate other people
as long as you don't want laws that are
different for them. Right. And will are
allowed to hate people. It just is right.
I don't have to be me
and her until to know.
I mean I, I, and, and I
think more importantly,
you are allowed to dislike the behavior
in which others engaged as long as you
are not attempting to compel them to
either engage or not engage in behavior
like this is way I think that there's
a fundamental distinction that every
religious person understands and a
lot of nonreligious people don't.
When it comes to issues
like homosexual marriage
or same sex marriage, which is, I don't
like a lot of things that people do.
I'm a religious person,
right?
That means that there are a lot of things
that Jews do. Like you don't sell it.
You don't take off Shabbat. Right. And
actually been trying to a little bit more.
Right. Well that's good. That's good.
Cause I want to get off my phone,
but bottom line is you or anybody,
anybody else,
lots of Jews don't celebrate Shabbat.
That's a sin from where I sit. Right?
That doesn't mean that I just like you.
Right. And I send all the time, right?
I violated Shabbat before,
either by accident or a while ago
when I was in front of on purpose.
Like th I do stuff in my daily
life all the time where I think,
am I missing the religion? Not a
perfect human being. Well, this is it,
but this is the religious thing. Religious
people understand that nobody is.
And so when we look at somebody engaging
in a behavior that we deem sinful,
it's not like we're sitting there all
day going, oh, I'll look at that center.
It's like, well, right. That's,
that's human beings, right?
We all sit and that's what we do.
And as long as I'm not trying to
compel you not to engage in the sin,
what do you even care like? It's, it's
confusing to many times.
Have I said to your face,
I actually don't care what your most
personal belief is on gay marriage.
I genuinely don't care.
I know this will be clipped a
zillion ways to sound people.
Now your head's get the tolerant
left, don't have Reuben's. You know,
and it's like, but I, I really
mean that. I sit on your shelf.
You were out there right now.
If you were campaigning for people
that wanted to flip gay marriage or,
or every day you were doing diatribes
about how evil gay people are and then we
would have a problem, right? But by
you taking the libertarian position,
you and your, and maybe from,
from your moral center and we'll,
we'll get into that shortly.
You're not thrilled with it. Okay.
I guess what I live in a country
with people that I don't agree with,
and this has been my perspective. I
mean, I said this on on Rogan show,
this is like they're legitimately millions
of people in this country who believe
that I will go to hell because
I don't believe in Jesus.
And you know what I think about
that. I don't care. I don't care.
Like it makes no difference to me.
Fine, you're not coming after me.
That's the best thing that's happened to
Jews and thousands of years that people
are coming after.
So like good.
You don't believe what you want as long
as you're nice to me and as long as you
are and as long as you, I don't even
think you have to be nice. Well I know,
I mean, but I mean as long as
you are at, yes. First of all,
you don't have to be right. I mean like
you may civil as long as you're correct.
I mean,
right.
And as long as you're not using the
government to compel me to do things.
And when I say nice to me, I mean
if you're not like people, look,
if we're talking about if I like somebody
or not, if you're overtly mean to me,
I'm not going to like you.
But when it comes to politics,
as long as you're not
trying to come help me,
I don't even care whether you like
me or not or I like you or not.
I mean that's a,
this is why in my view,
libertarianism is maybe the only way
we're ever going to be able to be able to
survive this stuff. Because if
we don't leave each other alone,
we're just going to club
each other and to submission.
I mean that's why I've been ranting
and raving about all this. All right,
so let's, let's shift to the book a
little bit. So I really enjoyed it.
And then this morning
you put up a or a Prager,
you put up a video that basically is in
conjunction with the book. So first off,
the title, the right side of history,
that's what the left always saying, right?
When you may not phrase.
So let's talk about that for a second.
Because that's what they always say.
Every time a conservative or any one
on the right remotely says anything.
They always say you're on the
wrong side of history, right?
No Mama most famously used that to
talk about same sex marriage. Right.
If you were anti
same sex marriage,
then this meant you were in the wrong
side of history and this who was the guy
that ran against games that,
correct.
She was on the wrong side of
history at that point though.
Then it became on the right side of
history. The reason that I use the phrase,
obviously it was a bit of a poke in the
eye to that phrase and it's a play on
words, is the end of the conservative side
of history, the right side of history.
But yeah,
there is,
but there's also this idea that what I
don't like is using history as a club to
beat someone with when it hasn't
unfolded yet. So people will say,
you're on the wrong side.
You don't agree with me on tax policy.
Well that was because in the future
it will be proved that I was right and
you're wrong.
And you were on the wrong side of history.
That's what Obama was saying about same
sex marriage was people who were saying
that traditional marriage has
been x for thousands of years.
Those people are on the wrong side of
history because history will justify my
position and they will have been shown
to be non progressive and non decent.
Maybe that's right. Maybe that's
wrong. You don't know yet.
History hasn't progressed yet.
Right. But there are certain, yeah,
it would be very scary though
if that was true that we would,
once things change that you would look
back and think that the thousands of
years before you, and this is
sort of what you're talking about,
the book that all of the people that
believe different things were we're
backwards or evil or on
the wrong side of things.
I mean it takes it no
context of how they live.
Right. And, and again,
I think there's a difference between
looking back saying here's a bunch of good
stuff that we have in today's society
and here's all the things that we love.
Where did that come from? That's what
I say, the right side of history.
Here's the stuff that we know that is
right and where did that come from? Okay,
so that's the right side of history
as opposed to here's my politics.
Today is my political position.
I have not a lot of evidence historically
that it's going to work or it's not
going to work,
but it will be proved one day that
you are on the wrong side of history.
If you oppose me,
you're not really talking about history,
you're talking about you know,
you're,
you're basically forecasting into the
future something that you can't possibly
know. So that that's sort of use of
the phrases is highly irritating to me.
Especially because there are times
when their politics in the ascendancy,
they're really ugly and unapproved
later to be completely wrong. I mean,
there was a point where Jews were pretty
regular getting murdered in Europe.
They were on the wrong side of
history at that point. Right?
And then it turns out
that in the long run,
they're not on the wrong side of history.
The Nazis are on the
wrong side of history.
If you'd said the opposite in 1934
people would have thought you were crazy.
So you can't really say
where history is going.
Well you can do is look back and say,
here's where history has gone and here's
what we like about what history has
been and here's where
we have broad agreement.
And that's really what I'm talking about.
Where are the issues where we in
Western civilization should have brought
agreement? And why is that broad
agreement starting to fall apart? Yeah,
so you know,
the IDW is a great example of this.
There's not a lot of agreement on
policy in the IDW virtually at all,
but there are certain basic principles
that we all kind of take for granted.
Democracy is better than dictatorship.
Free speech is better than limited speech.
Personal responsibility is better
than shirking personal responsibility.
Like these are things that, that everybody
seems to basically take in common.
And so what I say is, okay,
where do these values come from?
Because they didn't spring up in a vacuum.
And the fact that we have great material,
prosperity and free markets and wealth,
and all of this great stuff that did not
happen either by accident or everyone
at once.
Magic. It's not just some sort of man
made magic. So let's talk about that.
Let's talk about the two cities
then. Let's, let's start.
Let's start with Jerusalem
to Jerusalem. Okay. So the,
so the basic thesis of the book is a
very [inaudible] view, that thesis.
So Leo Strauss,
famous 20th century philosopher,
he posited that Western civilization
was predicated on these two poles that
we're constantly fighting with. One
another. One was Jerusalem and was Athens.
So Jerusalem is the idea
of Judeo Christian values
that under girds our social
fabric,
the vast majority of people who are
members of the community or members of the
Judeo Christian community in the West,
obviously.
And there are certain values that are
inherent in the Bible that are different
from most pagan cultures. So for
example, the, the Judeo Christian ethic,
and we can discuss where that comes from.
You know,
Jordan would say that it's rooted in,
in human nature and then
manifest in the Bible. Uh,
people like Sam would say that it's
sort of an evolutionary hangover. Um,
but you know, we can get to whether the
revelation actually occurred or not,
but the, but the basic premises of
Judaic Christian revelation there,
there are several of them.
One is that there is such a
thing as an orderly universe.
So this seems perfectly obvious to us now
that that we can discover the rules of
science,
that things are out there that make sense.
But for a huge majority of cultures
over time that was not true.
It was you worshiped various gods because
there are arbitrary that are fighting
with each other and you tried to
appease one at the expense of the other.
There are no discoverable rules to
the universe. He's weird though,
that you have to take a leap of faith
to get to a place that it starts with
order. Isn't that? Yeah, it's, it's
an interesting, it is, and this is,
this is one of the points that I make
is that people see reason and revelation
as intention.
But the point that I keep making two Sam
whenever we discussed this is that Sam
makes a leap of faith to
about these principles.
He and I started at the same principles.
It's just that I acknowledged that I'm
making a leap of faith to get there and
he thinks you can reason your way back
using sort of a priori reason to these
fundamental principles like
the orderliness of being
able to discover rules in
the universe.
I don't think any of that is perfectly
obvious to the human mind nor do I think
that for the vast
majority of human history,
people thought that you needed people
tended to think that basically your cork
bobbing about on the ids of chaos and
that there was no real way for you to to
discover any logic to the universe.
So the,
the idea of the Bible is there is a god,
the God creates a universe using a mind.
That mind is orderly in nature and there
are certain logical rules that that
mind uses and then we are
created in the image of God,
which has a couple of
separate implications.
One is that our mind reflects his to the
extent that we can grasp at a certain
level what exactly is the order of that
universe and then the second is the
actual meaning of that we
are made in the image of God.
It means that each of us has inestimable
value. Now that is something that, again,
we tend to think of as perfectly obvious
that we are all valuable human beings,
but all was restricted to the tribe
for most of human history and we are
reverting back to that now,
which is all,
you know we are all valuable except
for that guy. That guy is not valuable.
Screw that guy,
right?
He's a member of an opposing tribe and
so the story of Western civilization is
the broadening out of that principle
that we are all made in God's image too.
All right? That's why
when people say, okay,
well Western civilization had slavery
in Western civilization had racism.
It's that all that is true.
The question is why Western civilization
got rid of those things where it had
been trying to fight those things.
Whereas other cultures have basically
reinforced those things or have decided
those things are okay. And the
tribalism is, is a, is a good, yeah.
Thanks.
So what do we do that again about the
people that always want to focus on the
bad part? Because one of the things
I liked in the Prager u video,
you made a point of saying, yeah, a
lot of bad things have happened, right?
The West has made mistakes along the way,
but that the arc has bent so that there
is more freedom, there's more wealth,
there is more prosperity, all
that. But it seems to me that,
and I think this is what's
happening on the left by and large,
is that if they could
step back for a moment,
they might see that it's a lot better.
I mean, every college Gig I go to, I go,
I always open it up to the crown.
I say, does anyone have it worse?
I say this to the hecklers.
Yeah. And they never respond.
Does anyone in this room have
it worse than their grandkids?
And nobody ever says yes.
It's almost impossible if you
live in the United States,
if you're not honest with you,
until your grandfather could have been
an oil barren and then lost it. Right.
That's pretty much happy.
They'd be happy for that too because
they don't want inherited wealth to go
through the generations.
Right. But the point is,
it's very hard to get them to
look at that. What do you think,
what do you make of the type of
mind that always goes to the worst?
Is that because of the
disconnect with Jerusalem? Yes.
I mean, yes, because I think that
to a, to a certain extent you had,
and this is sort of
the thesis of the book,
is that if you're ungrateful for
this society that you've been given,
that's because you don't understand
the society that you've been given.
So we tend to think of all this stuff
is natural. It is completely unnatural.
There's point the journal Goldberg makes
in his book, right? The prosperity,
the fact that you have a baby, the baby's
will live to 80 in the United States,
barring some sort of
cataclysmic health event.
The fact that you are going to live
not only in relative prosperity,
but the greatest prosperity that
any human being has ever known.
You can go on a machine
and click a button.
Any product that you like will
arrive at your door in two days,
made in 10 different countries for an
affordable price that costs you less than
an hour of labor. Right in there. Like
thank God those people aren't going to
New York, right, with those 25 pounds.
Yeah.
So the,
so I think that one of the great debates
of our society right now is that on one
side you have a bunch of people who say,
okay,
well that's where things are awesome.
Things are historically awesome.
You wouldn't want to be born in any other
time in any other places in an amazing
place.
And all of the problems of history exist.
But what that's about is a struggling to
maximize the principles that were good
in their inception. And
then it's a question of is
fulfilling those principles.
And this is true for the declaration
and the Constitution. And yes,
slavery was contemplated in the
constitution and that was a great evil.
And then we find a great civil war.
And then there was racism
that was implicit in American
society than we fought.
We fought ourselves using these
great universal principles.
That's always ongoing, right? Of course,
there,
there is no end point at which all human
sin has been alleviated because we're
sinful creatures and we tend to
revert back into all of these things.
Tribalism and racism and, and illogic
and all of these, these things. But,
but the fundamental principles at the
root of the civilization are good.
And then you have a bunch of folks who
say, right, we have a lot of prosperity,
but look, there's still racism, there's
still sexism, there's still bigotry.
And that's because the actual natural
state of man would be the prosperity.
It's all this other stuff that
western civilization added.
And that I think comes from just a
complete ignorance of the realities of
history in the world,
which is that everything bad that has
happened in Western civilization, yes,
is truly awful and evil and also
has existed in virtually every other
civilization.
The history of the world.
The question is why is the
good stuff happening? Right?
The natural state of Man Hobbes is right
about this is nasty, brutish and short.
The natural state of man is not the
Rousseau's noble savage living out there
enjoying the fruits and the nuts. I mean,
that's not exactly what was going on,
right? This is the point
that that, that as I say,
Goldberg makes is that something happened
and suddenly we are all living in
paradise. So what was the
thing that happened? So the,
and this is where on the one hand,
I really accept Goldberg and Pinker
and the enlightenment argument and
[inaudible] argument in Michael Shermer,
his argument, I love the enlightenment.
It's so funny, people would characterize
this book is anti enlightenment. No,
it's very anti-friction.
Lightman half of the book is actually,
I mean that portion of this is correct.
It's,
it's funny how people sort
of see what they want to see.
So I've gotten letters from
religious people saying,
I don't think you're taking seriously
enough. The contribution of religion.
And then I got people from the
secular humanist side going,
I don't think you've
taken seriously enough the
contribution of Athens. Like No.
The whole point is that these two things
are intention and not only are they
intention,
but that tension is necessary.
I described civilization as effectively
a suspension bridge and on one end you
have certain principles you must take
for granted and that are embedded in the
Judeo Christian tradition.
And on the other hand you have all the
reason that must be used in order to not
end up in theocracy land.
And these two things are pulling against
each other and pushing against each
other and pulling against. And that's
the history of Western civilization.
And I think the greatest balance was
reached in the American founding and in
those principles.
And then those promises were expanded
outward to a broader and broader group of
people.
And that's the story of the
West as opposed to Western
civilization is the marks.
His take is that Western civilization
is effectively a power hierarchy.
All these principles are a lie and that
the principles are a simple gloss on,
on what is a reversion to a
power hierarchy. So for example,
there was somebody on the left who got
very upset because in this section,
the book I say, you know, we used to
believe that we are brothers and sisters.
We seem to believe that we
have these principles in
common. And people were like,
who's weak? He Hobby? Because a lot of,
cause a lot of black folks were not
included in that bargain. A 100% true.
But if you go back as late as 2006
2007 2008 and look at the poll numbers,
people believe that racism was
receding in the United States.
People believed that effectively. We were
trying to get rid of all of this stuff.
And the reason that we've been
able to curb racism in our society,
the reason we've been able to curb sexism
is because we were able to use these
principles to overcome the natural
tribalism and sinfulness inherent in human
beings, right? So when I say we used
to believe we were all brothers,
we did believe that we are all brothers.
But then we expanded the definition of
brothers. That was the story, right?
The reason that Western civilization has
been effective is because we have these
principles.
The principles are good.
We were too restrictive in the use of
those principles. And then using reason,
we broadened out those principles
to encompass more and more people.
So when I say we used to consider
all of each other brothers,
that was true in theory and not an action,
and then it would was
broadened out to action.
And that's what's made
our world a better place.
So is that part of the problem right now
is that we're in our eating fruits and
nuts stage here in the west.
We are in such spectacular
wealth and freedom
and all of those things in,
of course,
everybody's not wealthy and we have a
homeless problem in all sorts of things.
And there's problems, there's mental
health problems and everything else,
but that we have.
So by and large conquered races and we
have so by large conquered all of the
inequities in society. Not
all of them, but we've,
we've done a pretty good job and
we show it, as you're saying,
it's the train is still going right.
But that do,
that then becomes the weakness
that then people, young people,
and I mean if you look at the millennials
and now everything that was born out
of this new progressive lefty thing,
it's that it's not perfect.
So we must burn it down.
So it's almost that that is now,
but it's a symptom of the
success it's suppose to,
it's almost a inevitable symptom.
Okay,
well that's right. I mean this is what
I talk about in the book when I get to,
you know,
the sort of the philosophy of the 1960s
which was we need to replace the heart
of stone within man with a heart of flesh.
It was a religious concept.
It was from a Marxist idea,
which was there is something
fundamentally wrong with the western soul.
And what we need to do is shift the
entire system. This is the Marxist.
The actual market is pro
pro. Uh, promise is not,
you're going to be wealthier and more
spectacular and your living standard.
Then under capitalism, ver very few
marks is actually make this claim.
And if they do their ignorance,
uh, the, the actual match,
his claim is that it will fundamentally
change the nature of human beings to
live in different relations with each
other in a certain economic system.
And we will become different in humans.
Now the conservative view
and the religious view is
no, you won't, right? I mean,
you're going to be exactly the same
human you were before then the system can
change.
Human beings are always what they are.
You can alleviate certain
material conditions that
make people more likely to be
less stressed, for example. But overall,
human beings are sinful creatures.
We tend toward toward tribalism and anger.
We have to train ourselves to be good.
Anybody who's had kids,
I'm frankly astounded that anyone who
has kids buys into the Marxist, he says,
because the notion that kids are there,
that people are inherently good.
It's such absolute utter crap. That
doesn't mean we don't have good instincts.
We do have a good instinct,
but that is balanced for the very
selfish instinct as well. I mean, I,
I know there's a, there's a new
book out. I'm trying number who,
who's the author was just reviewed in the
Wall Street Journal talking about sort
of the natural goodness of,
of human beings and I, there,
there is some of that, I mean look
at as Jordan, let's talk about,
if you look at Piaget,
people play games with each other and
they tend to form common rules and all of
that is true.
There's also a real selfishness to human
beings that naturally comes out and you
see it among kids.
And if that's not trained,
if people aren't cultivated
to become better human beings,
they just don't become
better human beings.
And so this is why I say you
need to reexamine what it
is that's good about your
life and then ask, why did it get so
good? You didn't build this thing like,
I don't want to, I mean, I
do want to quote Obama care.
Obama says you didn't build it. When I
spend my entire life building a business,
but you didn't build the system, the
system you were born into. Right.
You think that free speech is something
that just magically exists here and that
everybody is entitled to it.
Yeah.
Welcome to a thing that that only exists
for the last couple of hundred years
and legitimately millions of people
had been killed fighting over.
Is this why?
What is happening right now with the
Democratic candidates is so dangerous.
I mean,
just in the last couple of weeks,
so now they're talking about reparations.
They're talking about adding Supreme
Court justices. They're talking about,
there was a whole slew,
I give me a give me [inaudible]
electoral college, Electoral College.
I went to the Senate, the Senate,
because it's not represented
my population. Yeah. Yeah.
These things that these are
now would be, you know, look,
these ideas were man made ideas,
but that they think only in their day.
If they can just rejigger the
entire way we look at everything,
it will be better.
Where I would argue in almost every,
I can't imagine a case where if we flip
to any of those things, things would,
would be any,
yeah, no, I,
I really have serious doubts that if
you get rid of the Senate that suddenly
people in Montana are going to be like
totally okay with everything. Right.
Or that people like let, let's not
pretend that people in California
aggressive in the big cities
would control everybody.
Right. And, and by the way, the people
in the rural areas, we try to break away.
I mean, they would, that's the, the,
the, I mean people don't want it.
The civil war was about slavery and
there was also a massive economic gap
between the south and the north,
which was reflected in a lot of the
tariff fights that existed up until the
civil war.
That was a rural urban gap.
And it's one of the reasons why the north
one is because they had so much more
urban power than the south.
But you know that that was about slavery.
You could see a certain situation in the
United States where the rurals look at
the cities and they say, we don't want
you ruling us. You don't live out here.
What do you,
why should I listen to a bunch of people
live in San Francisco when I live in
the Central Valley of California?
I'm a farmer out here.
Why can't you leave me the hell alone and,
and you know,
I used to at least be able to punch above
my weight in terms of you used to have
to take my opinion into account.
Now you can just ignore me
and run rough shot over me.
Why should I be part of that system?
I don't buy into your majority Terrian
system where you are always the majority.
That's not something I'm interested
in. You know, the, the, the sorta the,
the tracks that the founders did not
trust peer majority hereon doesn't mean
they were right not to trust peer majority
Arianism because majority of people
have often believed incredibly
stupid and dangerous things.
That's why they want
to checks and balances.
We've sort of run rough shot over those
over the course of the last century.
But yeah, I mean the, the,
the fundamental disconnect
between conservatives and
people on the American left,
uh,
is summed up by Chesterton in,
in his very famous fence analogy that
if you're on the left and you're walking
through a field and you see a fence
in the middle of the field just in the
middle of nowhere, you're first instinct
is, I don't know why this fence is here.
Let's take down the fence. This fence,
it does not belong here. It's just dumb.
There's no reason for the funds
to be hurt. Get rid of the fence.
If you're on the right,
your first instinct is to say,
I'm not going to remove the fence until
I know why it was here in the first
place.
Once I figure out why I was here,
then we can talk about removing the fence.
And that is true right now in politics,
the, the left teams to be saying,
I don't know why any
of this stuff is here.
They even ascribe bad history
to these things, right?
They'll say that the electoral college
has put in place to protect slavery or
some such nonsense, which is just not
true. And then the end and then it's like,
well, we created this false
history. Let's get rid of the thing.
I don't know why it's there in the
first place. No reason. Dump it.
And people on the right.
Whoa, maybe we should like,
think about what the actual possible down
sides here are because virtually every
action that we take has some
unintended consequences.
And maybe we overstate the
Like I think that has probably happened
for example with gay marriage, right on.
I used to be anti same sex marriage on
the legal level. I used to say like,
I think that if the government legalizing
same sex marriage that it's going to
have some pretty dramatic impact on how
people interact with one another. Um,
and then I was,
and then before Obers fell,
I said we should get out of the business
specifically because I don't want
anybody imposing their
views on anybody else.
We can all live how we want and
just leave each other alone.
And I think the the right
overestimated kind of pushback.
Did you get from religious people on that?
I don't know that we've ever
actually specifically talked about.
I don't know that I got significantly
heavy pushback specifically because I
wasn't making the case that you have to
overrule your own vision of what's in
constitutes. I'm just saying you
can't impose that on anybody else.
Meaning that if you want to protect
yourself from the other side using
government for its argument,
then you need to stop using
government for your argument.
I was making the anti
institutional argument, right?
I wasn't making the case that everybody
who's religious has to re shift away
from their religious orientation.
I wasn't doing the Hillary Clinton thing
where it's like a certain amount of
religious people. I get that.
Yeah. That I make obviously,
but I would imagine a certain amount of
religious people if they're viewing this
as sort of a foundational societal belief,
right?
If you change this institution,
I'll tell you,
I didn't get a ton of pushback
specifically because I
wasn't coming out against
the institution.
I think a lot of the pushback that
surrounded same sex marriage was a twofold
idea from the religious community. One
was you must personally in your own life,
except that same sex marriage is morally
equivalent to a heterosexual marriage.
And if you don't, you're a bigot. And
that offended a lot of religious people.
People were like,
I don't that,
that's not an argument I'm willing
to listen to because you're,
you're immediately labeling me a bigot
based on both my religious views and a
view of natural law,
which is fairly common to most religions
and I'm not going to hear that.
I think that if the, if the
left had approached it as
you don't get to use power,
we don't get to use power,
nobody gets used power the
right is much more receptive.
That's been my argument all along.
So I think libertarianism has a lot
more draw than social leftism two to the
right.
I think you can make,
can solve most of those problems by having
the government just not be involved.
This has been my contention,
right?
I could cause what I'll say to religious
people as I may even agree with you on
the nature of sinfulness, a particular
activity, but it's none of my business.
And not only that, I think that if
you make it the government's business,
you know you're all happy to use the
government right now for your particular
ends,
but there's gonna be a time when you're
not running the government anymore and
they're going to come for you and
you're not gonna be real happy. Right.
They don't seem to like this Trump guy.
Right.
They get their answer is more government.
Exactly. So that's why I didn't,
I didn't get a lot of pushback when I
suggested that because it wasn't coming
from a place of me trying to castigate
people for their own personal moral views.
And I think that for, for a lot of the
gay rights movement, it was about that.
It was about, it was about,
I'm trying to castigate people.
If you believe that what I do is I send,
that's because you're a non
meritorious intolerant bigot.
Does that also show you the,
the,
unfortunately religious people have been
tarred with this idea of intolerance
when it isn't true. I mean, is
that like a really good succinct,
I mean I think that's a good example
because the fact is that listen,
has there been religious intolerance
toward people? 100%. I mean, come on,
I can't pretend that that doesn't
exist in the Jewish community,
exists in the Christian community,
exist in the Muslim community.
It's true that there's been intolerance.
I quite like,
I don't want to portray religious people
is all completely innocent in this
cause obviously that's,
there are people who have been
excised and treated badly by religious
communities. Of course that's true.
But this is what I was talking
about earlier with, with,
with Buddha judge his treatment of pens,
the track,
the attribution of motive depends as the
pence is sitting there like day in and
day out thinking, oh, that people put a
judge in his, in his sexual proclivities.
Like that's, mm. I don't know
anybody who thinks that way.
If they do think that way,
there's something wrong with
them, frankly. Yeah. Um,
and it's, and so that's, and also we did,
it came out of a of a year of me to
where it was like right before all that
happened.
What was everyone making fun of pence
over that he doesn't go into rooms with
other women and yeah, that may sound
odd to me or you know, all right.
That's what he's decided to do. And
guess what has been not accused of doing,
some of them are frankly, listen, yeah.
Spending Jewish religious
law for a very long time.
You're not supposed to be alone with a,
with a woman who is not your
wife with the door closed.
This is like legitimately part of
Jewish law and it has been for several
thousand years. It's called the acid.
You're not actually supposed to do it.
So like Mike Pence said that, I was
like, oh, well welcome to the club dude.
Thank you.
What do you do in a situation like that
then? So if you're in your office and a,
and a female,
cool. I mean we've got glass doors, so
it's not as much of an issue, right.
Meaning like,
you know,
I don't really thought it all through
[inaudible] like I never want to be in a
position where I can be accused
of acting with impropriety.
And by the way, this is true
for doctors too. Like I'm,
I'm shocked that people took
pens that way. I, my wife,
who is a doctor when she goes into, she
is, it turns out I can't believe when she,
when she goes in and she
examines a patient when a,
when a male doctor
examines a female patient,
the new rule basically is there must be
some third party in the room to ensure
that there is no claim
made against the doctor.
It seems to me if you're a prominent
person then you should be considering
exactly the same thing.
Like this doesn't seem illogical to me.
This just seems like for the same reason
that I like body cameras on cops as a
general matter,
I like evidence and I like people who
are there to debunk or enforce the, the,
the actual account that happened.
So is this another one of
those things where they,
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions. Where the idea of course is,
you know, we're gonna put everybody in
situations where the you, I wouldn't care.
I don't care if the person that I
hire, I don't look at their, I mean,
when we did our last job posting,
I made a point of saying,
I don't care about your gender.
I don't care about your sexuality.
I don't care about your skin color,
et Cetera, et cetera. But in reality,
because the world is so out of whack
right now, the truth, the real truth is,
I don't know that I've ever said this
publicly. When we were looking at resumes,
I was less inclined to hire a
gay man because I thought, well,
I could be in a room with this person
and then they could just announce that,
listen, they're writing.
How insane is that?
So now you've created a scene because
you create the system of incentives that
it doesn't help anybody.
Right.
[inaudible] you've seen actually this,
this sort of thing materially
speaking in terms of, for example,
policies that say that you're not allowed
to do criminal background checks on
potential employees because there are
too many black folks who have criminal
backgrounds and so we want to make
sure more black people are employed.
You actually end up with a reverse what
you end up with his employers who look
at resumes and in many cases cannot check
the criminal background of people and
so they say,
okay,
statistically it's more likely that a
black person went to prison than a white
person went to prison is
not a racial statement.
That's a statistical statement of fact
and so I'm just not going to hire this
black person. Well, who gets hurt by that?
That black guy who didn't commit
a crime, right? Yeah. This is,
this is the sort of thing that like there
are dangerous unintended consequences
to public policies that are,
that are well intentioned. Again,
I think it's a well intentioned public
policy, but I think that it's a,
a bad public policy.
And to pretend that people aren't
people as stupid people are going to use
whatever information they have at
hand to make judgments and to protect
themselves. And this is, this is true if,
if this is true with regards to employers
and women taking time off from the
workforce, this is true with
regard to sexual harassment
allegations. Like, listen,
when I was growing up, my mom always said
to me, right, and my mom ran businesses.
I mean she,
she was a higher up at the company that
did hell's kitchen and she did like
major reality TV shows. So she was
a high powered when my mom worked,
my dad stayed at home and my mom said
to me, if you ever get a secretary,
get a 70 year old woman,
right?
Because you're never going to be
accused of anything cause she 70 Riley.
And that was my mom saying that to me.
Some people have that fetish,
but
it as a general rule like this,
but,
and that's not entirely like human
nature is human nature. In this,
there's been this willful attempt to blind
ourselves to human nature that I find
alternatively hilarious
and ridiculous and scary.
It's like what we're supposed to pretend
that reality doesn't exist because we
wish reality. We're not what
it was. And the truth is the,
the unhappiest people on Earth are
the people who are constantly fighting
reality. Whether you're talking about
in your dating life where it's like,
I want to look just exactly as I feel
like looking at everybody else who won't
date me. It's their problem. You
can't get a date. And I said, well,
maybe it's because you haven't worked out
in 10 years. Right. Stink, right? Or Yeah.
Or, or maybe a or whether it's in
the job market where it's like, well,
I wish that I could get this job and I
deserve to get this job and I'm not going
to do what I need resume wise to get
the job or I'm going to rely on such and
such to get the job that I don't get
your order or I'm going to sit in this
dying town.
I'm never going to leave this dying
town because I deserved to have a job in
this tiny town.
The nice thing about politics is you
can pander to everybody by lying to them
about these realities.
Right.
Did you, did you happen to see last
night, I think it was on 60 minutes,
there's a clip going around of this
young, you saw this, this student? Yeah,
or they, they interviewed several
students and the thrust of it,
I didn't see the full thing.
I just wrote what they tweeted out,
the videos that they tweet it out,
but the rest of it with
all these young people,
but there's this particular
young man saying, you know,
if college was free in medical school was
free and that I wouldn't have to work.
And then because of that, I could study
more. Thus I could be a better dot. Right?
And it's like,
hey,
there's no proof that that's actually
true and you might learn a lot of things
by working and all that.
Now the idea that med school maybe is
too much money in college is completely
out of whack. That's a perfectly
legit conversation to have. Right?
And we can't have that conversation,
but I just thought the way it was spun
by the Twitter account was like, see,
it's obvious you shouldn't have to work
if you're going to be a doctor. Right?
And it's like, no, no.
Right. We're missing
something here. That's the,
so what was funny about that
story is CBS news covered it as,
isn't this a great example
of why we should make medical
school for free? Right.
And what actually happened
is there was a donor
I believe is Bernie Marcus from,
from home depot who went to
Nyu and he donated several,
I believe it's like a hundred million
dollars to Nyu to pay for the medical
education of the kids who went to Nyu.
So as a private donor doing something
good for these kids and they're like,
what if we just made a government policy?
Well then you completely skewed the
incentive structures. What would happen,
because I'll tell you what would
be the next thing that happened.
The next thing that happened
is that doctors would be,
would be granted free tuition presumably.
And the next thing that would
happen is they would say, okay,
well now you have to be regulated so
you need to work for 60 grand a year,
at which point the registration
rates would dramatically drop it.
And you get a completely different crop
of people who are going into medicine in
the first place because you know that
you're going to get free education,
but you're only gonna make 60 grand,
70 grand on the other end.
All those people who right now are paying
$200,000 to go to medical school so
they can make $400,000 a year coming out.
All those people decided to
go work at Mckinsey instead.
That's all that happens because people
are profit seeking and want to live a
certain lifestyle and guess what?
After 11 years of this shit like my wife
deserves to be able to earn whatever
she can earn. I mean, I've been doing
this thing, okay, I've been women,
like I cannot tell you how many,
how many things we've had to forego and
I've paid for her medical education,
right? I mean, I've gone
out of pocket for all of it.
I've paid for every iota of her medical
education and it's cost us a lot,
but she's working for below minimum wage
right now because doctors and residency
effectively worked for below minimum wage.
They're making 40 50 grand a year and
then working 80 hours a week and that's
what they go through.
And you know what?
That's because they should
make money on the other end.
The market does have a value
in determining what the
value of these things are.
The two solutions to that are either the
market or private people like the home
depot guy come in and that that frankly
I think that it's just, it's not perfect,
but frankly I don't think
that nobody's forced.
I don't think that there
is a serious, yeah. Okay.
So there are a couple of things you can
do to bring down medical school tuition.
One, you could stop with the licensure
requirements for things that nurse
practitioners could do.
Right?
Because that way you have bunch of people
who are going to nursing school or PA
school and they can do a lot of this
stuff and then you don't have to create
this cartel and the cartel charges a
lot of money too for you to get into it
that that'd be one thing.
But number two, so what,
so you take out a bunch of loans to go
to medical school and they make a bunch
of money coming out,
which you should make because you
have spent a lot of money going in.
Like if you want,
the question is do you want your doctors
to be people who make a lot of money?
Do you think doctrine is an important
thing as a society such that you want the
smartest people going into it?
If you want the smartest
people going into any industry,
you have to make sure that the pay
grade is high enough and I'm at,
my problem here is not
free medical school.
My problem is that it will be used as
an incentive to to force doctors to take
less of a cost for Medicare for example,
and then you will get a lesser group of
people intellectually than you otherwise
would. There's an unintended
consequence to this sort of stuff.
So he's this just the fundamental flaw
with almost every argument that comes out
of the progressive these days that if
you give free college that this will
somehow ultimately do good.
Even though we know that there are more
jobs disappearing that you wouldn't need
college,
but that will be the free,
you can go to trade school or or any of
these things where it's like we can or
Medicare and then the free
college education. The,
the free college education argument is
one of the worst arguments I've ever
heard. It's legitimately a terrible
argument. I mean the idea that look,
everybody in college is earning more
than people who didn't go to college.
Therefore if everyone went to college
they would all earn more than that. No,
I'm sorry.
The reason people earn more from going
to college is because it is a sorting
mechanism. If you get rid of the sorting
mechanism, you know what will happen.
There'll be another sorting mechanism,
which is exactly what's happened with Grad
schools. The vast, a huge number of it.
Like as you sort,
the incomes go up and as you get rid
of the sorting mechanism that our new
sorting mechanisms that are added to
the job market and to the educational
market while you're actually getting,
unless you're actually, you know,
going there for math or science
or something, but as I said,
if you go to college and I went to
Ucla and then Harvard law school,
so I have plenty of experience with,
with going and majoring in useless things
and major university, you were Ali's,
I mean I was a poly sci major at Ucla,
which is a useless thing
in a major university.
The all that these things are are twofold.
A sorting mechanism,
because I went to Ucla and Nazi son and
that means that presumably I'm smarter
because it's a higher sat score to get
into Ucla than it is to get into Csun and
second,
a an Ersatz social fabric where you
meet a bunch of people who then you can
later on call on his friends.
Right.
This is what JD man's talks about and
hillbilly elegy coming from Appalachian,
going to Yale law school.
Suddenly he has a group of people he
can call on and he's part of the social
fabric and he's operating
in different social circles.
Neither of those two things are going
to be cured by universal college because
the social fabric goes away because it's
not selective anymore and the sorting
mechanism goes away because it's
not selective anymore. Right.
So so do you get free college no
matter what your major is? Well,
this is the other thing, lesbian dance
theory, that Free College, right?
What did we give to society when you're
not qualified to do anything? By the way,
Buddhist judge has exactly right about
this. This, he was correct on and he says,
why are we having middleclass people
subsidizing people who are upperclassmen.
Totally correct.
The people who are going to end up in
college enabled to get into college.
You're going to be the people who would
have been able to go to college anyway.
We don't need more
people going to college.
When you have fewer people going to
college, we need less useless majors.
We need people being able to apprentice
directly into law school. We needed it.
Like why is it that you have to be 23
and you've gone through seven years of
education to go to law school? Why? It
makes no sense. Why couldn't you just,
when you're hiring right now
because daily wires killing it.
You guys are growing fast.
You're,
you're doing all sorts of stuff over at
the office. Uh, when you look at resume,
I don't know how involved,
yeah, yeah. My best partner,
Jeremy is much more involved but yeah.
Do you even care that much work experience
matters more than where you went to
college? For sure. I mean,
Jeremy is a perfect example is my
business partner didn't finish college.
He went to a music school and dropped
out after two years and people used to
look down their noses in it.
And I remember there was a very prominent
person whose name everyone would
recognize who one's called up,
Jeremy Cursing at him because
he had not gone to college.
And Jeremy was like, why? Like Jared
and Jeremy now runs a company that,
that, you know, we have close
to 100 employees. We clear
a lot of money every year.
We grossed a lot of money and the,
he knew some of the smartest people I
know never went to college or finish
college.
Like it's,
it's good for what it's good for
and it's bad for what it's bad for.
It's good for premed. It's good
for math. It's good. It would be.
I got a lot of flack for saying
this about, about kind of the,
what we call the north campus majors
at Ucla. Uh, the, the, uh, po,
the poly psy
English history majors.
And I said like,
basically this is effectively
useless and you should, you know,
unless you're majoring in a hard science,
you should think about going elsewhere.
Like, well, your whole book is about
Western civilized philosophy look, right?
We don't learn any of that crap.
Go to college anymore. Well,
that's the reason I wrote the book is
because none of these people learn any of
this stuff.
Nobody's ever heard of.
A client is when you go like when's
the last time they taught Aquinas at a,
at a major university other than in
sort of religious studies classes.
They don't even mandate
western Civ anymore at these
classes nor I mean like the
stuff should be imbibed with your
mother's milk. I mean they should be,
they should be part of just the
generalized educational curriculum.
If we want to go down in the
conspiracy road a little bit.
Is that part of it too is that if you
really wanted to keep indoctrinating
people with lefty ideas and socialist
ideas and big government ideas and all of
those things in collectivist ideas,
we'll give them free college and then
just teach them those ideas for four years
and then you've really whacked
them at the knees before they,
I mean I think there is
there. To me it would
make sense. Bernie say go,
everyone's getting free college and what
are we going to do to you at college?
Teach you postmodern.
I think. I think it's less
conspiratorial than that,
but I do think that there are a bunch
of people on the left who certainly are
not upset about the fact that colleges
are dominated by the left and who are
very angry every time somebody tries
to break that domination. I mean,
this is why I get banned from colleges
speaking about stuff like this. So it's,
you know, again, it's, it's a
pretty hardy policy. How do you,
how do you take the ideas
between Jerusalem and Athens
and how do you then just
beat the easy ideas of the day? Because
that's, to me, that is where we're at.
So now we're just at a place,
a easy answer.
Everyone that I disagree with is a racist,
bigot.
Homophobe I know how to do everything.
Everyone before me was evil.
All of those things,
let's change everything.
The current laws in electoral
college and everything else.
Let's do all of those things because
we're so good and everyone else so stupid.
Well, how do you actually
beat that? I mean, that's what
right, trying to do, right? I
mean, I think that the first
thing to do is to, is to,
you know, get people involved
in reeducating themselves.
And I think you're taking tremendous
hunger for that. Obviously.
I mean this is a book on
Western philosophy and in
the first two weeks we sold
well over a hundred thousand copies.
It's a book on Western philosophy, right?
And that is not exactly pop reading.
I mean that's not right.
It's not happy dappy do kind of stuff.
So it's ignored and told
people how to clean their room.
And so 5 million exactly. It. That's
exactly right. That's exactly right.
I mean like there's a market for,
for hard stuff right now because people
are looking for something that means
something and we haven't created
a much better world with,
with the Twitter woke police out there.
I don't think that people are feeling
happy or secure because of all that.
So do you think it's
fundamentally a crisis of meaning?
That's really what I took away from
your book yesterday and I really,
I was thinking about it over the weekend.
It's like nut. We listen, you know,
we fight on Twitter all day long.
We all siphon off into our own little
places and now between fake news and
everything else, it's like nobody really
knows in the secular world lit. Yeah.
Nobody really knew has this, and this
is the sadness of liberalism right now.
For me,
it's like maybe liberalism didn't give
enough through a secular lens and PR and
I think maybe you'd argue that's
because he got disconnected from, uh,
from Jerusalem.
Uh, people not bet that we're in a
crisis. We're in a crisis of belief.
I think they are crisis of reality.
Here's what,
here's night real argument with sort of
the secular version of the enlightenment,
the French German version
of the enlightenment,
which is that by disconnecting the
connection to Judeo Christian values,
the idea was that we were
going to untether ourselves
to be able to fly to the
stars,
but can make our own meaning.
And I think people suck in making
their own meaning. Frankly.
I think that generally when
people make their own meaning,
they tend to fall into hedonism or
nihilism. I think that there are,
some people can do it, right? Yeah,
for sure. Some people can do it,
some people can do it. Some people can
live with this. I mean I think that Sam,
it seems like a fulfilled guy. Michael
Shermer is a fulfilled guy, right?
I think there are,
there are people who can,
who can live with this and
make their own meaning,
but for the vast majority of people,
the answer is absolutely not.
You cannot make your own meaning because
if you make your own meaning you tend
toward either selfishness
or meaninglessness.
You need to be told that your life has
value and that you're in control of your
own life and there needs to be rooted,
rooted philosophy to support that.
And that begins with teaching
these very simple stories.
I mean I it fundamentally,
I think that religious education begins
with the stuff that is harder to believe
because that's the most simplest to
understand. Its hardest to believe in,
simplest to understand,
right?
The stories in genesis are the
hardest to believe on their face,
but they're also the simplest
to understand like you
get from the idea of Adam
and eve, that you are not the creator
of your own meeting, right? That,
that the knowledge of good and evil,
your knowledge of good and evil is not
the same as God's knowledge of good and
evil. And that by attempting to
create your own meaning, it's a,
you're actually egotistically
sending against God. That's,
that's the message for the Adam and Eve
story or the Canine and Cain and Abel
story,
which is that ceaseless jealousy and a
belief in your incapacity to take control
of your life that that result
in violence and cruelty, right?
That's the basic issue of can enable
which has god says to Cain, you know,
Tim Shell, you can do this. And then kids
like, nope, I'm going call my brother.
And that's it. And you see that down
and it's an aspect of human nature.
You teach these very simple stories to
people, David versus Goliath, right?
All of this can be the big guy right here,
right there.
There are plenty of great stories that,
that embed fundamental values.
Cause this is how you teach
kids. Everybody teaches
kids secular and religious.
You teach kids stories.
Like when I read in my daughter at night,
I'm not reading her from, from Sam's
book, she wouldn't understand it, right?
Or I'm not going to read
her enlightenment now or,
or how the mind works by pinker like,
Oh,
you have to start with certain fundamental
values that the fundamental values
are generally rooted in story.
This is where Jordan is totally correct
and those are deeply embedded in the
human psyche.
And so there's an immediate resonance
to a lot of the biblical stories,
which is why the Bible has
staying in selling power. Uh,
and then you use those stories in
coordination with reason to expand those
stories outward and to develop. Right.
But you have to always stay tethered.
I mean it's,
you can lengthen the chain,
but at a certain point the chain breaks
and then then you're off and running and
then you got a problem that the point
that I'm making here is that I think the
West has,
has undercut its own allegiance
to fundamental principle
and they thought that
this would allow the rise of reason to
dominate and what it's instead allowed
for is in the worst cases,
some really horrible things.
And in the best cases, yes,
it continuation material prosperity,
but also in a crisis of purpose and
meaning that's happening to people where
they're looking around, okay, okay, I'm a,
I'm a ball of meat wandering
through the universe, purposeless.
I don't have free will. I don't have
the capacity to, to control my own life.
What am I supposed to do now?
So I think basically what you're saying
is you think it could work for awhile
that Athens alone could work
for a certain amount of,
as long as it's living off the
fumes of the Judaeo Christian ethic.
And this is the point that I made to Sam
when we debated in San Francisco was I
said, Sam, why is it that we hold
the same values? Because we do,
we have on a fundamental level, we
have basically the same value. So why?
And he said, well, I've studied
this and I've studied this.
I've studied eastern philosophy. This is
where I get my value. So that's great,
but why are ours the same? Right? Because
I haven't studied any of those things.
So why are those the same?
And I don't think it's because I've
studied deeply in the Bible in Sam hasn't.
I think it's because we both grew up
on the fumes of this culture, right?
I mean we grew up 10 miles
from each other in Los Angeles.
That seems to me a better kind of
historical explanation of why we believe
fundamentally the same things.
Then that he studied one philosophy
and I studied another philosophy.
So do you think we're in
the fumes stage now? Yeah,
I think the theme is running out. I think
that Jerusalem, the Jerusalem fumes,
and I think that as the Jerusalem
fumes run out, so do the soda,
the great hopes that were behind
the reason based enlightenment.
Meaning that one of the points
that I make is that the,
the enlightenment makes fundamental
assumptions that are unsustainable on the
grounds of the enlightenment,
meaning the enlightenment
argue the secular enlightenment
and that non American
Anglo Enlightenment makes the argument
that basically we are Spinosa this stone
where bald meet wandering
through the universe. No,
we'll have our own no free will.
I mean Sam wrote an entire book
about there not being free. Well, um,
and that we don't have the capacity to
choose. And when Sam talks about reason,
as I asked him before,
like,
so according to evolutionary biology
reason is just a beneficial firing of the
neurons. But you make a moral
argument in favor of reason.
So my question is on what basis,
what if there was a more evolutionarily
beneficial firing of the neurons?
Say genocide, genocide. This is
Hitler's rationale. Effectively
just apply Darwinism to the social
sphere and we can effectively wipe out
everybody who we don't like.
And that will better humanity by getting
rid of the weaklings and they can move
on. I have also correct, Dan has had,
Thanos is on board with this by the way.
Dennis has an infinity songwriters and
you just create more resources anyway. Um,
if you met a genie with the first
thing you wish for more wishes,
but in any case, the, the
fundamentals of the enlightenment,
which are reason freewill,
the capacity to make your own decisions
are actually robbed by scientific
materials.
And if you're a scientific materialist,
I don't know how you sustain the bay.
Like Sam says he believes in
objective truth. I agree with Sam.
There's objective truth.
It's fascinating.
Jordan doesn't believe in objective
truth in the same way, right?
Jordan believes in a sort of
Charles Pierce, Charles Purse, um,
pragmatism with regard to truth.
That truth is whatever works.
And so there's certain things that have
been proved to work in those are true,
which is attractively useful
for evolutionary biology.
Sam believes and objective truth.
Like there's an truth out
there to be discovered.
There are things that are true and
there are things that are false.
I totally agree with him. You believe
that, but not for the same. Well,
I don't know. Well, as I asked him,
I don't know what his reason is.
Meaning Sam says that stuff, and I don't
mean to rip on somebody, but I mean,
I talk about all this in the book and
I'm sure he can write a really cogent
response cause he has a bright guy.
And I really like his stuff.
I hate doing this when he's not
here. Yeah, no, I know. You know,
we should do it when Sam's here so
we can discuss it, but it, but the,
the fundamental point that I make is
if you are going to argue in favor of
reason,
if you're gonna argue in favor of will,
if you're going to argue in
favor of all of these things,
you need to make some fundamental
assumptions that are simply not objective.
Truth.
W evolutionary biology doesn't speak to
objective truth and speaks to what is
useful to a species that allows
it to survive and thrive.
But it doesn't speak to what's true if
the species didn't exist with two plus
two equals four be true. Sam would
say yes. And I would say, why?
Because the species doesn't exist to use
it. So what, what does that even mean?
There's the Judeo Christian ethics and
this is where Greek teleology in Judeo
Christian ethics made, you know,
the Greeks, Aristotle, Plato,
they believed there was such
a thing as an objective truth.
They believed that there was such a
thing as a universe that a cosmos that is
understandable,
they believed in the idea of free will,
that you could make a
difference in a cosmos
leaving in it, you would say is
just not enough. Right, right.
Just believing in the,
in the rational mind is still not enough.
Right. And the, and when they do
get as a type of belief, right.
And I think that they attempt to, they,
they attempt to prove back to, you know,
the unmoved mover.
And that's a good starting point.
This is why Aquinas is so reliant on
Aristotelian theology at the same thing is
true for my monities. They both, uh,
like the, the, the greatest, I think,
attempt historically to merge
the religious philosophy
of Judeo Christianity and
the,
and the Greek philosophy of Aristotle
and Plato is simultaneously done in the
Islamic world and the Christian world
and the Judaic world actually, uh,
it's done by Alpha Robbie in the,
in the Islamic world and it's done
by my monities and the Judaic world.
And it's done by, by Aquinas
in the, in the Christian world.
And it's an attempt to merge.
But in the merger you,
you sort of lose the tension that's
necessary I think because when you
completely merge than it,
then you end up in the same place as the,
as the theocrat, which is okay, so natural
law and theology are exactly the same.
So let's just follow the theology.
My bottom bothering with
this reasoning it out thing.
There is no reason to do that.
I think the tension exists for a reason.
So then getting us back. Then how
do we get out of this thing, this,
this polarization that we seem to be in?
Which I do think,
I think you got it right
here is the tension between
these two cities right now.
So how do we break this?
Because we're all sort of caught in
it and I've also been thinking about
something that we've talked about a
bunch before that we're running out of
communal spaces or communal events to
have anything left to bring us together.
Nobody really watches
the nightly news anymore.
We're after game of Thrones goes off after
this. Yeah. We're basically out of time
and, and we're, and we're stuck with it
and we're still with cultural events,
not actual meaning based event.
Right. We don't have a go into the, we
don't have a moon landing coming up.
You know,
we're really running short on,
I mean July 4th parade are controversial.
Yeah. Now when you upgrade to it, yeah.
You're parading genocide or something.
I mean it's all nuns. It's,
but as this tension ramps up,
the fact that we're now have
no spaces to let the vents off.
That seems to me to be the biggest thing.
Yeah,
I totally agree. And this is not just,
you know, people in the right thing.
There's people on the left are
recognizing this and Robert Putnam's,
a sociologist at Harvard,
he writes with the scraper called bowling
alone and in it he talks about the,
the sort of meme diversity is
our strength. And he says, yeah,
I used to believe this.
Diversity is our strength stuff.
And then I looked at the social science
and what I found is that as ethnic
diversity in a place increases,
the only two things that increase our
protest marches and television watching.
Unless unless there's a common purpose,
there's a common purpose,
then diversity is your strength.
So in other words,
if you go to a church and you'll get
the church, a bunch of diverse faces,
people have different experiences,
but they're all there to
have a common purpose,
worship God and take care of each other.
Then diversity is great.
All the experiences, you can tell each
other about it. You have the same goal.
That's all fantastic.
He said the same thing about the army.
You go to the army and you
see an incredibly diverse
group of people. I mean,
we know, we both know a lot of people
who serve in the military and the,
the amount of cross racial friendship
in the military is amazing, right?
For people who just grew up in a secular
society and where it's like, yeah,
I have my black friend and but that's
not true in the military and the military
and people legitimately bond across races
because they're forced into proximity
where they are like sports,
nobody cares.
Corrected sports is another great example,
right? They have the same common goal.
Well, so the question becomes for
our society, what is our common goal?
And it seems like that common goal is
receding because some of the fundamental
things I think that we are all
supposed to agree on, right?
The free speech democracy, the use of
freewill, the use of responsibility,
even things as fundamental
as that are dissipating in,
in response to people saying,
you know what? All this is a lie.
The only way to attain power and
protection for my group is returned to
tribalism, which is intersectionality
on the one hand and,
and white supremacy on the other.
Uh, or we are going to get rid of,
of all of this stuff in the name of the
collective because the individual no
longer matters like the,
I talk in the,
in the book about this could a fourfold
matrix for human happiness that we all
exist as human beings on a couple
of levels as members of uh,
as individuals and then as members of
community and we are all these things,
right? I mean people will
say the communist will say
you're just a member of the
community basically. And then libertarians
will say you're only in individual.
And the truth is neither of those things.
You are a member of a community and
you're an individual and they are
simultaneous and inextricable.
And so you need to,
so the human happiness in individual
exists when you have the following,
four things in, in a society can exist
when you have the following four things,
individual, individual purpose.
So you get up in the morning,
you're on a desert island,
what do you do today or you nihilistic.
Do you have something to do? What
makes, what gives you meaning?
Communal purpose meaning what can we all
get together to do and what's our goal
together as America?
Are we here to spread liberty?
Are we here to preserve liberty?
Are we here to create economic equality?
What is our goal as a community and how
do we not quash individual purpose in
that there has to be a balance, right?
Cause if communal purpose is too strong,
you quashed the individual and
then there's individual capacity.
You have to feel like you as a person
are in control of your own life,
capable of forging forth into the kind
of adventure and wilderness which is the
American mentality and you have
to have a communal capacity,
a system that allows me to,
as an individual thrive while allowing
us as a community to mobilize when need
be.
If you have these four things,
then you can be a happy individual and
you can be have a happy society. Now,
the way I think this is the best
balance in terms of government is that
government is weak enough not
to attack you as an individual,
but is strong enough to mobilize when
we really need to mobilize to protect
those individual rights and to protect
the, the system at large. That's,
that's where I think the founders got it.
Exactly right.
It's why I think that I rely to a very
heavy extent on the social fabric as
opposed to the government to
create a fake social fabric.
I think the left relies on the government
to create a sense of community.
I don't feel a sense of
community in government.
I don't care about the people
in government. I don't think
they care about me. Uh,
I think that the people who care about
me or in my family and my community,
I think the broader,
the more broadly we share values,
the more I care about people
in the broader community. Um,
but there's a sense on the left that the
way that we created social fabric is by
having a very powerful government.
In 2012 was at the DNC when they
flashed on the overhead screen that the
government is the only thing that we all,
the only the government is the only thing
we all share. And I thought to myself,
well that's a big budget lash that
on this. Yay. I was like 1984 right.
It was very, it was, it was
really late. I saw it. I was like,
I can't believe that this is a
thing that's up on the screen.
The only thing we all
share really like that's,
that's where we were all
participating together.
Cause it seems to me that we all,
we all share in a bunch of different
things and the fewer things we engage in,
the more we're going to need to
rebuild that capacity from outside in.
I don't like outside in.
So what do we do then about the nationwide
or navy? It's not even nationwide.
It's worldwide now.
I mean the things that we're after
this last year of being on tour,
the same things that we're talking about
here all the time within an American
context or happening in virtually
every western society at some level.
So what do we do to rebuild some of those,
those common public spaces?
Like what?
What is it we should be doing?
So I think that the help, so there,
there are a couple things. One,
the government really
needs to stop tearing down
religious institutions because
historically speaking,
religious institutions have
been the bulwark of of the
social networks that most
people rely on. And we living in big
cities don't tend to rely on it as much,
but out in the sticks,
people really rely on this stuff
push for, for my atheist viewers and my
left is shores that may remain or the
progressive's. Can you give them one
more push on why they should fear that?
Okay.
You shouldn't fear that because so long
as there is not government compulsion
from religious people in religious
communities towards others,
the fact that people are belonging
to churches is a wonderful thing.
They're supporting each other.
They're giving charity do each other.
They're there making sure that
you don't have to pay for them.
They're the ones who are making sure
that there is a social fabric people can
rely upon. You want less
opioid overdoses. You want,
you want less people who are
unemployed and unemployable.
You want less people who are following
and falling into deaths of despair.
They need a social fabric. You're not
creating it and don't pretend y'all are.
You're sitting in the city far away from
these people and when you rip on their
church, when you suggest that their church
is the obstacle, you're taking away.
The one connection to social
fabric that people have.
Tim Carney has a new book called alienated
America in which he looks at various
communities when he finds is that
it's not even an economic thing.
People on the left and the
right populous are like, well,
we can fix all this with
the economy economics.
We just put some tariffs here
but put some subsidies here.
We grant universal basic income that's
going to fill this gap for these people.
The question is not lack of benefits,
their unemployment benefits,
and there's welfare and food stamps.
There's plenty of benefits
available for a lot of people.
That's not the question.
The question is where do you find
connection with other human beings?
And while you can sit in a place where
you feel like you have connection,
and especially if you're
a college graduate,
who's watching this show in a big city,
you do have an Ersatz social connection.
I look at different kinds of their senses
and write a different kind of social
connection with people you went to
college with and people you hang out with
that doesn't exist in huge swaths of
the country and the for the first place
people go to get connection is their
church. When those churches disappear,
the communities die and then people there
are left without even the motivation
to move. So that's one thing
that then secular. But again,
this is not restricted to religious
people like me in court saying this there.
Robert Putnam is a secular guy. He
says, you get rid of the church,
you've got a real problem on your hands.
There are plenty of sociologists who
are looking at the death of churches and
saying,
what's going to fill this gap?
Well, I see it now. I mean, I don't come
from that default position necessarily,
but I do see it now. I mean, after
being with Jordan on this, toward the,
when he would talk about the
importance of the stories, a religion,
I could see people there.
There's,
it's not a coincidence that people could
start thinking about these stories,
the messages in these stories.
And then suddenly there were thousands
of people that I was meeting that were,
they stopped doing drugs and they stopped
drinking and right amends with their
children. Or, I mean, every
day I saw this, right?
This is it. Right? And this
is, I can't be a coincidence.
And this is the other element of, of that,
that we really need to reinstall Kate.
And that is that the smart people
don't have all the solutions.
But the one thing that you can do is
solve your own problems. And this is,
this is a mindset thing.
So notice that everything that I'm saying
has nothing to do with governmental
compulsion.
It's the opposite.
I want the government out of everything
because I don't think the compulsion is
going to fix any of those.
The the biggest thing that needs to
change is people need to re embrace the
spirit of adventure in their own lives.
And this is something that I really
believe that this is the thing that makes
Jordan most popular, is that this is
what Jordan says, life is a struggle.
Life is chaotic. Life is difficult. Go
and forge forth in spite of those things.
And this is what makes you a man, right?
This is what makes you, uh, a woman.
This is what makes you a person worthy
of having freedom. I think that's true.
I think it's fundamentally a religious
message in nature and it's certainly an
inspirational one. And we have a society
where basically said to people, no,
you know what? You've got a
problem. I can solve it for you.
The smart people will solve it for you.
We'll solve it through.
Ubi will solve it through tariffs,
will solve it through,
through going after China and Mexico.
You never going to have to
leave your hometown. It was,
I had this conversation with
Tucker Carlson and Tucker's
really interesting dude,
and we were talking about specifically
his sort of anti-tech takes. So He's,
he's very concerned about self driving
trucks, destroying millions of jobs.
I'm a little bit more sanguine about that.
I don't think it's going
to happen overnight.
I think that you need drivers behind
the wheels. But in any case he was,
there's one point during the conversation
where Tucker said something to the
effect of,
yeah,
so you're going to say to a bunch of
people who are living in the town where
their grandparents are buried that
they need to pick up and move.
And what I'm saying is they should
be able to stay there and have jobs.
And I said, right, like
this is the, you said you,
you want them to leave
the town where their,
where their parents are and where their
grandparents died. And I said, right,
or biblically speaking,
leave the land of your fathers and go to
a land that you know, not right. I mean,
this is the spirit of
the individual forging.
Fourth is what made the country fantastic.
One statistic that is just
utterly astonishing is that
in an era where we have
this rising underclass of folks
who have sort of been left behind,
we have less mobility in the United
States than any time in modern American
history. People are leaving home less
often than they didn't. People are saying,
well, it's because they're
living with their parents. Fine.
Why aren't they moving where the jobs are?
I mean,
this was literally what every one
of our parents did, right? I mean,
I don't know where your parents grew up.
My parents grew up in Chicago and they
moved to Boston and they moved to La,
Brooklyn. Right, exactly.
Like everyone in California's original
story was that no one was born in
California. Right? Like
very like I was born in La.
I'm one of the only people I knew who
was born in La, right? This is, and that,
that sort of movement,
this,
this hunger to go out there and adventure
and take control of your own life.
That needs to be reincarnated and
that comes, we have to try it against.
Did you move him on that at all? Because
I know that I'm on Tucker tonight. Yay.
I went on all the time and I have
these discussions with him and um, uh,
did you move him on that?
I'm not sure.
I,
I don't really think so. Right. I mean,
this is the fact that you
don't care about your feelings.
Think what he's saying there. It does
feel right. Like if your whole family,
if your family lived in a town mining
town for 100 years, it doesn't feel right.
I mean, this is what I would
say about the baker and the,
and the gay wedding cake.
It's like,
it doesn't feel right that
you can't get the kid there,
but that doesn't mean that the government
should fix the problem or can fix it.
Right. And this is, and again,
I think that there's a
mentality shift that's happened.
I think it's true of immigration too.
I think it has real policy ramifications.
This idea that you were born in America,
therefore you're owed a bunch of stuff.
And I just don't think that that's,
frankly,
I don't think it's a good perspective.
I think on a religious level
to not a religious perspective,
and my perspective is that
you're effectively owed
nothing, right? You're old,
you're owed the adventure,
you're owed the freedom to be able
to do what it is that you want to do.
And then the reason you need the social
fabric is to help the people who can't
do it without the the hand up.
And it's funny you talk to people who
live in religious communities and because
they've had the social fabric,
they instinctively feel like the
government has filled a lot of the social
fabric in a lot of big cities.
But you talk to people who live in
religious communities and everyone has a
story that's like this where it's like
there was somebody in the community who's
struggling.
So the rabbi got together a bunch of
people and they give them some money and
like I knew where the money came from
and he went out and he made a plan and he
fixed it. And, and that was
the way that things got fixed.
Now is that going to fill
every single gap? No.
I mean you do need local government.
Sometimes to fill these gaps.
Local is better than national because
you have more sympathy with people who
live close to you and you see the impact
of the problem where you live. But the,
the idea you need a social fabric,
it, it's why I don't consider myself
libertarian even though I'm libertarian on
social,
on government policy.
Because I think the mistake that some
libertarians make is to suggest that
libertarianism applies on a social level
to limited government in and of itself
is enough to keep everything going.
Right. And I don't think that's,
I don't think that's correct.
I mean I think that rights and duties
are two sides of the same coin.
And as Washington suggested that,
you know,
you need a moral people
to sustain liberty.
So this is a bit of a non sequitur
sort of. Well maybe not. Um,
so do you think this is why the left is
going so bananas with the Jews at the
moment that there's some connection
there because Jews did get up and when,
I mean, when you want me to slugging
that conversation, we're talking,
I was thinking that's the end of
the fiddler on the roof. Right?
They don't want to leave
when a buy to a Lazar Wolf.
They don't want to leave. I'm going
to Chicago. You're going wherever.
But it's like we have to go now.
We have to forge something new.
And Jews have kind of
been doing that forever.
And that is the antithesis of
what the left is offering now.
So I think there is truth to that and
I don't think it's restricted to Jews.
I think that you've seen
the intersectional hierarchy
changed radically based on
which minority groups are
perceived to be more successful.
So what you see is the,
is the left suggesting that Asians are
no longer minorities in the United States
can't get into heart rate. You
can't get into Harvard. You're not,
you're not truly on the
intersectional scale because you're,
and now they're doing it with gay folks.
Right.
Gave Asians everything when
they came here. Exactly.
The Asians and Indians just get
everything. They were just, you know,
work in these hard jobs and,
and wrote a little hot dog stands at
seven 11 it's just because that was,
you know why not. Exactly. Exactly.
And then you worked hard and you see
this as happening on the fringe left
already with, with gay folks. Right.
So the idea that you saw that article
at slate where they did this with boot
with Buddha judge,
where they were like,
well it's intersectional enough cause he
grew up white and he grew up privileged
and he went to good schools. But also
he's gay. So he's a little intersection.
He's not like intersectional to suppress
[inaudible] rectus accounts as a gay
guy. Legitimately. Did he come
in as a gay guy? I think was,
that was sort of the headline was like
he's not fully like, I don't understand.
Well he's married to a man. So
last I checked. Yeah. I mean like,
well first of all, I'm not even
sure what they're going for their,
except for he doesn't rate high enough on
the, in the, uh, oppression scale. Well,
the craziest one of those that I
ever saw was a couple of years ago,
I think it was,
it was either out magazine or advocate.
I can't remember which one,
when they said that Peter Teal is no
longer gay because his politics don't line
up with gate. So what would really make
you gay? The physical part? No, no,
that doesn't fact. It doesn't
matter. What matters is how we feel.
And you're going to have,
by the way,
they'll come after Camilla
Harris on the same grounds. Her,
her born parents is Jamaican. One
parent is Indian. I mean, that's,
that's not traditional. Grew up in
the inner city. I mean, her, her dad,
I think it was a professor at
Stanford or something like they'll,
they'll come for, for anybody
who doesn't like, we'll,
we'll pretend intersectionality
applies until it no longer apply.
Does that make you very hopeful then?
Because I think we're seeing
minority groups crack.
We're seeing Asians go, whoa, whoa, Whoa,
we don't want to be on the
reverse side of Jews are finally
going, wait, we don't have to vote
80% democrat black people. I mean,
just the fact that now
reparations is becoming, uh,
virtually every Democratic candidates
are talking about reparations to me,
regardless.
I know you have a little bit of a
love hate thing with Canada's Owens,
but it's like she did. And
just like Hannah said, no,
no, no, no. I don't need this.
Like, but I mean, you guys,
you guys go at it and that,
that's fine. Uh, I think more,
it's like, I just sit here and sometimes
she doesn't baby. I was with them.
They were a couple of days ago. She
likes you. I meant more that you don't,
you just don't agree on everything.
That's correct. Yeah. Point being,
when I see all these
Democrats suddenly going, oh,
we should have a commission to figure
out reparations. It's like, Whoa, they,
Candice really must've done something
here within the black community because
now all they're going is
all we got left is cash.
Well, I think that they're, you know,
I, I hope that that's true. You know, I,
I don't know the data bear it out,
but I certainly hope that there is that
cracking that that is taking place.
But the left has a couple of very
powerful forces in one of them is as we
discussed,
the attempt to make it uncomfortable,
to have different thoughts or to engage
with people who have different thoughts
that you are no longer welcome in
the circle of the, of the woke.
If you have a conversation
with somebody on theirs,
I mean legitimately have a
conversation or watch a video.
I mean there was a story that was out
of anything was Michigan state two weeks
ago where a student at Michigan
State College fix reported.
This was watching one of my videos on
youtube and the roommate made and it made
a rights violation complaint to the
administration at Michigan State for the
student watching my video.
And the administration was
like, fine, we'll move you.
I mean like,
yeah,
like W it's come to the point where
if you mentioned names like people who
legitimately don't know anything about
you don't know anything about cannabis,
don't know anything about me.
You don't know anything about Jordan.
They'll make claims about people they
legitimately cannot back up cause they
never engaged with their content.
But the very fact that they
haven't engaged with the content,
is there a credibility on
speaking on the content?
Because if they ever
engaged on the content,
then they wouldn't believe all these
things but they don't engage and therefore
they are good. Lack of engagement is
good. Right? It's not that you engaged in,
now you're better because you've had a
better conversation if you didn't engage
or better. So those are the, the in,
that's the countervailing
intimidation factor that's,
that's taking place in that I
think is still quite powerful.
It's why every single
democratic hands in it.
I mean it really is incredibly powerful.
Every single democratic candidate
effectively skipped Apac this year. Yeah.
Because Ilhan Omar has impact
and because folks on the end,
because folks on the hard
left hate Israel and,
and that has impact and then they
all showed up for Al Sharpton who's
legitimately one of the worst
people in modern American politics,
like in modern American
history speed or he,
he ran a Jessie Smollett a
hoax and accused and actual
human being of committing
a rape against a black
girl who was not raped.
He accused even Ponas of raping a black
girl and then scrawling racial slurs on
her body in shit. And he is, it
was not, it was all false. Yeah.
And he, he was, he called
Jews, diamond merchants. He,
he suggested white interloper is we're
taking over Freddy's fashion Martin there
and then somebody wouldn't burn
down the place.
Like he's the worst guy I'll sharpen.
And every Democrat showed up at the
national action network because to be
welcome means to be in
the club like we don't,
here's the thing about those of us in the
Idw, people think that we have a club.
It's not a club,
it's just people who like to talk about
things and anybody is welcome to the
club,
which is why you see like these weird
videos where people who we've never talked
to her had conversations with our
suddenly quote unquote members of the IDW.
Like we talk with each other
and there's like a core group.
I think of us who every so often like
really every so often go out and get
drinks or have dinner. But
that's like, that's not a,
that's not the same thing as this.
You're unwelcome in the club if you don't,
if you don't do acts, like that's,
that's not a weird thing that if the,
if this way, if the Idw,
let's say whatever it is at
the moment, you're right.
It's not a co, we're not walking around
with a card. We don't have a clubhouse.
But like if this collection, and then
of course it's way wider than just us,
but if this middle collection,
which seemingly,
it's pretty small and it's kind
of getting smaller because it's,
it's just getting tougher to
have centrist opinions. Right.
And also this thing doesn't hold.
Yeah.
I mean that's right after and when you
can see and you can see out viciously
left is trying to carve it apart by,
what they'll do is they'll come after me
and then they'll ask you for comment or
they'll come after Sam and then they'll
ask me for comment or they'll come after
Jordan and they'll go after it. But
that's why I think it's important. I know,
you know, people attack me. Oh he's
always, he's always shitting on the left.
But it's like this is the perfect example
of what's going on here on the right.
Does anyone on the right relentlessly,
viciously and dishonestly attack
the Weinstein brothers or, or, or,
or Sam even or anyone that's on the left.
They don't,
I mean they agree to disagree. If you
read that really is as simple as that.
I mean it's amazing.
If you read the comments on the,
I take Yang as an example
cause it just happened.
But if you read the comments on the
Sunday special that I did with Yang,
there is nothing like,
legitimately, I never read the
comments, but I was curious.
There is nothing but appreciation
that Yang would even come on the show.
That's the entire thing.
It's like, oh look,
a cordial conversation between
people who disagree. That's so nice.
Like how pathetic is it that
that is considered like the
big win here? There was,
there wasn't a single comment about like,
Oh Shapiro destroyed gang there
cause that wasn't the purpose of it.
Everybody got what it was supposed to be.
It's a conversation and that's great.
Did he move you on anything like a UBI
situation? Let me, I'd read this book.
I had read his book and I,
and I didn't find it
utterly convincing on a ubi.
I think that as I've said before,
when it comes to ubi,
if we reached the point of absolute
crisis where nothing else like it,
let's put it this way,
ubi as a negative income tax in lieu of
all of the welfare systems we currently
have, I would sign onto it in a heartbeat,
right? The idea of we get rid of,
we get rid of real repeal and
replace, right? If your appeal,
all the welfare programs and you replace
it with a single check that is signed
then, but I think the promises of Upr
a little bit too big for his Britches.
So people are saying, well it'll solve
the opioid epidemic or it'll solve the,
as I say in the book, I think it's a
crisis of meaning not a crisis of money.
And so I don't think that's
going to solve it. Uh,
if the idea is that people
are going to be liberated,
as Andrew says in his book to go and
do art and volunteering and charity,
I don't see any evidence of that.
The part, I don't write that,
that's the part where I was like, um, no,
even even if you could get me on the
robots are replacing all our regular job.
So let's say you could get me on that.
And the other part is just that it takes
away something about fundamental human
nature about what you're talking about
before about the individual going out
there and getting theirs.
Right.
You would just end up having this class
of people that would be given just
enough. I mean I have a
new welfare. Right, right,
exactly. And when he said was,
well,
it's not enough to actually live on,
it's just enough to actually
supplement and what I said,
so what's the limiting principle?
Like is it just the 1000
or is it politician going
gonna come around next week
and say it to be 3000 and then you hit,
what did he say that, cause I haven't,
he didn't,
he didn't really,
I don't even really firmly addressed it
because that's the key question, right?
It's like, well, okay, we can also
in bucks and we're good at, correct.
Literally the next week there will be
somebody who says 1,001 bucks [inaudible]
gonna say about the lefties who won a
thousand, they'll call them racist or,
that's exactly right. No, I mean there
are some problems and implementation of,
of Ubi that exists with the welfare state.
Also,
a lot of the studies that suggest that
there's the same level of employment,
those are temporary ubi attempts.
Right.
If they were a permanent ubi,
uh,
I think that you would see a decline in
employment. But also, as I said to him,
there's a conflict between what ubi says
it's trying to do and what it actually
would do. So I think it would do
the same thing as the welfare state.
And that's why I say like as a
replacement for the welfare state,
I'm kind of warm to it, but
it's like, let's give it a shot.
Basically saying that's
failing, let's, right.
And also because I'd rather have the
government sign and understandable check
rather than you have to go through it.
You have to de de incentivize
work or deincentivize fatherhood,
or do you know all of these
incentive based structures?
I'm not a fan and they've been
rather ineffective, but it,
but as a general principle, the idea that
it's going to solve the work of crisis,
what he talks about in his book is the
crisis of people who don't have jobs and
that crisis is the not having of the job,
not merely the not having of the money,
signing people up, check in lieu
of a job. It doesn't actually,
like he points out in the book,
number of people on disabilities
been rising dramatically. Right?
They're all getting a
check and are they happy?
Are they spending their time volunteering?
Are they spending their time down at the
local waystation helping people or are
they, you know, will taken
drugs. It all sounds good.
Medicare for all it sounds good.
We will have the same thing that we know
that that's not going to be the case
because of course,
well now they're talking about getting
rid of private insurance, which is insane.
I mean that's fully what they have to do
it because otherwise doctors just will
not accept Medicare reimbursement rights.
I mean, that's the reality. Again,
you know,
as somebody who works closely with people
in the medical industry and in fact
sleeps with a person in the medical
industry, you know that, you know, the,
the idea that doctors are going to just
accept 60% on the dollar of what they're
making right now is
absolute sheer nonsense.
But also it's such a disconnect of
what, of what I think they view. I mean,
I get it that they think government is
something that I don't think it should be,
but it's like,
what right.
Would the government have to tell a
doctor he can't be in the private business
that he wants to be in. Right. And
they actually think that's okay.
I mean quite literally
Tamala and I think uh,
Cory booker and nothing and said they
think it's good private insurance.
I mean this is another,
this is another thing that I asked Yang
about cause he said he was from Medicare
for all and there's a section
in his book where he says,
so how are we going to deal with the
fact that doctors are going to just stop
going to medical school? Cause
that's a real thing that will happen.
I mean already
if you want to see how perverse
incentives work in the medical industry,
look how many people come out of medical
school and going into what are called
the road. And the the, the road
fields is radiology, ophthalmology,
anesthesiology and dermatology. Why?
Those are the least regulated fields.
There's the least Medicare there.
Nobody's taking reimbursement rates.
Those are all areas where people basically
show up with an insurance company or
cash in hand. Yup. That's
where everybody's going.
It's where all the money is.
So that's how per first incentives work.
He says in the book,
what we're going to have
to convince doctors that
basically they need to rethink
about what the lifestyle
of a doctor is going to be.
That they're not going to live high on
the hog anymore, that they're going to,
you know, be putting out more for
the public service. And I've had,
well you can do that,
but it's not gonna be the same people.
Do you think they how to do that? No, I
mean he, he sort of says that we should,
that we should just,
people will,
will have to be informed that the
incentive structure is different.
And here's the thing, if you have
a different incentive structure,
you are going to get a different thing.
My wife would not have gone to medical
school if you were assured of comp for 11
years,
if you were assured of coming out
making $65,000 or $100,000, right?
The, the reality is that you
wanted a certain lifestyle.
It's why she went to medical school.
You change those incentives.
You think all these guys were going into,
the surgeons are going to spend years
on end doing this so that they can then
work for years on end
working for Medicare.
Does that sound the awesome to anyone
like this is the reason that smart people
become doctors is because smart people
would like to make money and be paid for
their work. This is why
smart we'd like, yes,
there is a self sacrificial
component to all of this.
It's there easier ways to make
money than being a doctor.
But to eliminate the money factor is to
eliminate half the reason that people
become doctors in the first place.
You want a lot more people called
a lawyers in Mckinsey associates.
This is the way to do it.
I have a good friend.
What pro two or three best friends from
childhood since second grade who was
like my chief sparring political
partner, our our whole lives. Uh,
and he's now become a huge
Trump supporter. And why?
Because he was a doctor, went to
medical school, raised all the debt,
realize he could never live
in New York where he grew up.
He's now in Texas and he's often doing
things that have not to make money now
because it's so hard. And then he became
a Trump supporter because of Obamacare,
because he was crushed with paperwork
and bureaucracy and nonsense and now to
make money because it's so much
harder than just doing the procedures.
He's basically doing like, like
medical real estate things. Yeah,
and it just shows you how the whole
system I, but that's just one guy,
but it's like, yeah, the
whole system is out of
factors are going into concierge care
specifically because of this. Yeah,
I mean they're very full apps that exist
where you're paying like 99 bucks a
month and then a doctor
will show up at your door.
Like there's so many ways that we could
make medical care so many online should
be such an asset for medical care.
Right? We should, there's so many weeds.
Getting rid of licensing requirements,
as I suggested it would be a great thing.
Like there,
there are things that we can actively do
to do this and the truth is for healthy
people and for people who have
private healthcare insurance.
There really isn't a problem. Like we
like to talk about how it's too expensive.
Why do you think we have millions and
millions of jobs in the healthcare
industry? Like what do they think happens
when they nationalized this thing?
All those jobs just transfer over to
government or are a lot of those jobs lost
because those people don't
work for anybody anymore?
Why is it that the people ignore
the upsides of Robo? Do they think?
Does anyone answer that question?
What are you going to do with all
those people and not the private? No,
they can all be hired by the government
to do nothing. Right? And then do they,
and nobody seems to understand that the,
the reason that the majority of new drugs
and procedures are discovered in the
United States is because we are
paying those outsides prices.
So when Trump says that we are paying
for everybody else, that is true,
we are paying for everybody else. But
if we stopped paying for everybody else,
they just will stop producing those
drugs here because why else would they
produce the drugs here? Like
this is, our system is not good.
But to pretend that our system is like
the worst system on planet earth or the
people are dying. I mean quick
statistic then nobody likes to site.
But it's true if you get rid of,
of shooting of homicides and car
accident death where people die.
Like at the scene from
the American death rates,
America is the number one life
expectancy in the industrialized world.
Those are not medical issues.
Those are issues of people shooting each
other and people get in car wrecks a
lot here in the United States.
So you know,
that's as far as I spending per capita,
like insane amounts of money.
Can we spend more than other countries?
It is relatively in line
with the OACD income. So for,
for on a per capita income basis,
we spend a lot of money.
We also make a lot of money here in the
United States and the medical industry
here is a huge part of
the American economy.
All of Pittsburgh is basically the medical
industry now as opposed to the steel
industry. And that is a very
good thing for Pittsburgh.
So the answer to a lot of this is
deregulation. Not reregulation, but again,
those are conversations
I think that can be had,
but I think that people are not being
realistic about what they expect from the
system. And they're not realistic about
the downsides of, of systems that are,
that are completely nationalized.
I mean, in my opinion,
if you're actually gonna get the
government's equally involved,
we've got to have a Swiss system where
basically people are paying a percentage
of their salary into private
insurance and then they are,
and then they are expected to do that,
right? Like the individual mandate,
if you're gonna get the government
involved is not the world's worst idea.
It's just that it's now stacked with
enormous amounts of regulation, uh,
and inefficiency and bureaucratic and
efficiency and that. But I think again,
that a free market is better
than any of that stuff.
But I also think that you ought to
take responsibility if you are on it.
If you don't buy insurance
and then you get hit by a car,
I'm sorry that that
would be a you problem.
Like th th th that's why we need a
social fabric where I care about you.
But on a governmental level,
this idea that you're not going to
increase the rates of use with government
care is just a lie. People are going
to pay for those people no matter what,
right? I mean, right. It's against
the turn them around, right? It's,
you are going to pay for
it. Right. But it getting,
getting hit by the car is
usually not the real issue.
Usually the real issue is how do you
pay for the person who didn't buy health
insurance for years and then gets, uh,
it gets hard condition that requires,
you know,
here's lawn care.
Like the person who was in the
yard is going to get paid for that.
We all end up paying for it
with an elevated insurance
rates and all the rest of
it. But um, yeah, the, the problem
of the chronically unhealthy,
which is a very small
percentage of the population,
but the most expensive percentage,
that is not really a rationale for
overturning healthcare that 90% of people
seem to enjoy. Like it also is
gonna make you hate people for
no reason.
You're going to go to in and out or
Mcdonald's and see a table of four obese
people stuffing their faces,
drinking hi from social and Syrup and
everything else, and you're going to go,
wait a minute. These people are all,
they're living [inaudible] there.
This is horrible. I mean,
this goes to the community.
It's no one wants to look
at that and think, yeah,
well this is, this is, this is why, you
know, I've said people who try to compare,
for example, the Nordics,
the Nordic health care model,
to the US health care model. You're
not comparing equivalent populations.
People eat healthy things in Norway.
People in the United States eating
nothing but crap all the time.
I was just in Norway, Sweden, Finland,
Denmark. These people look good. Yeah,
right. I mean, this is, it's a, it's a
much healthier population and this is why,
if you actually want to compare
the efficacy of healthcare systems,
you don't look at the generalized
population of the United States and the
generalized population
of Norway, certainly tiny
country with 5 million people.
I mean the La County is 11 million
people or something. Right? Well,
what you do is you compare people who are
Norwegian in America to people who are
Norwegian in Norway,
and what you find is that people in who
are Norwegian and America outperform on
nearly every aspect.
People who are Norwegian in Norway,
then you're comparing apples to apples.
Like we compare apples to oranges
and then we're like, well,
why doesn't this work over here?
Because they're not the same thing.
That's why it doesn't work over here.
All right, Shapiro, let's go
dystopian. You're ready? Okay.
Let's say everything that
you've written about here,
everything that we're trying to do,
all these conversations,
we will having it all, it all just
explodes. It does not work. We,
the ideas that we're fighting for fail
in the face of postmodernism of what's
being taught at this college is of what
the media is throwing at everybody and
we get more and more of these people
in government and all of these things.
I think about this sometimes that what
will happen to the outlier people like us
in the future. Do you ever,
do you ever think about that?
But I think that right now,
for example,
for all these people that think
Trump is Hitler and all this stuff,
Trump tweets anything and then a hundred
blue check journalists talent to go
fuck himself and you're going to be in
jail and a zillion things and Trump does
nothing. That's not even a defensive
anything. Trump says that's just reality,
but now let's do it the other way.
Imagine now we've got one
of these far lefties. Yeah.
Bernie's Bernie friends who believe
that government is the end all be all to
everything and now the outliers who
have all been called Nazis. All right.
The Ben Shapiro's and everybody else that
had been called the worst things that,
well now,
now government and tech is against us
and now we're doing the same exact things
that the left these up today are doing.
Yeah. How do you think that's going to go?
Well,
I mean this is why at daily wire,
and I know you've been looking into this
to alternative means of distribution or
the entire ballgame.
I mean that,
that we understand that
when it comes to the left,
you cannot live on their large ass and
like forgot taking the beginning of the
year.
They came after me and tried to boycott
me over making most anidine point on
abortion I think I've ever made in my
life. Right. They, they, they tried to,
they legitimately tried to knock
my sponsor's off my show. Yeah.
For suggesting that pro lifers don't
want to kill any baby no matter what that
baby would turn on to be because we don't
believe that you can kill babies for
any rationale based on a
minority report reasoning,
and I mentioned baby Hitler in this
context because they'd been a thought
experiment that was by
people up to an including
Tom Hanks or legitimately years and they
tried to boycott my show based on that.
I mean it was insane the,
so we're not focusing on living on large
ass of the left when it comes to this
sort of stuff. We're building a
subscription system at daily wire.
This is why we encourage people to
subscribe because then you can get our
content no matter what you do. Cause
we, it's all vertically integrated.
I know that you're looking at stuff
like that as well. Um, you know, on,
on a tech level we're building
alternatives and that's
what we ought to be doing.
A, on a generalized level, I think what
we're watching and it's really pretty sad,
is that people like us are going to end
up in places with people who agree with
people like us.
Meaning that I live in a Jewish community
where I'm pretty popular because it's
an orthodox community.
I'm more,
I went to lunch with you at a kosher place
and if I had to take one more picture
of you,
I was gonna.
Yeah, exactly. I mean that's,
that's the, those are my folks,
but I've spent my entire
life living in Los Angeles,
a place where the vast majority people
disagree with me or in Cambridge where
everyone disagrees with me. And that's,
and I like that. I think it's nice.
I think like I think it's good that there
are conversations happening across the
aisle as the left seeks to basically
censor or destroy anyone who even engages
in those conversations where
Joe Rogan becomes an outright,
cause he has a conversation with me
because I once had a conversation with you
and you once had a conversation
with Alex Jones, right?
Like this is the way that it works.
Clearly we've all pushed
people to the next,
right? I mean, but the, the, and
this is, and so once that happens,
all it's going to happen is it's going
to make places like this on livable for
people like us.
And I mean even people who just want to
have conversations and then you do end
up with a real gap in the country that
is almost unbridgeable where it's like
everyone agrees in one place and
nobody agrees in another place.
And that's where the, if
the, that's why honestly,
the checks and balances
system is so vital.
We mentioned before because of people
in Texas feel like they're running being
run roughshod over by people in California
and the national government or the
other way around. That's not going to
last. That's not, that's not sustainable.
Right?
So that's why it's like I don't really,
I like doing this as a thought experiment
more than like what could potentially
happen.
But it seems to me that if we have been
no code spaces that we were talking
about before and we all do have to get
siphoned off into our own thing just
because that's the way the tech landscape
is going to work. That it's like, yeah,
we got the checks and balances in
our system is, is pretty damn good.
I would say probably,
I would say it's the best man made thing
set of ideas probably in the history of,
of all time.
Um,
but how can it survive in an
information war? You know what I mean?
How can it survive in a
time when for all we know,
the next w whoever runs for president
isn't going to accept the results of the
election. Stacey Abrams still not
accepting the results. Like they're,
they're underminded,
they claim Trump wasn't going to accept
the results of the election and now it's
like that's what they're doing.
They're trying to undermine everything.
And if we don't have enough coast
spaces to work it out, this is is why
we have a very short window right now
to pour resources into grabbing as many
eyeballs as possible and ensuring
that as many people see countervailing
material as possible because you just
don't know when that window is going to
slam shot. Yeah. I mean that really was,
you have to grab as many people as
possible and let them know that there are
alternative places where they can
get your stuff. Because you know,
here's what I'm concerned about mostly
when I'm concerned about is that you're
going to see a move by Democrats in
Congress and from the presidency to do
exactly what Mark Zuckerberg wants.
Right.
Where are the FCC is suddenly regulating
speech on Facebook and to relieve the
obligations of Facebook
to do it themselves and
suddenly if you are labeled,
not outright, but outright adjacent. Yeah.
Based on the fact that you want
to interview the person who wants,
interviewed a person who wants stood
next to a person who was once wearing a
shirt, then you know, then you're
screwed. So that, that, that's where I,
I don't think that the,
the, this is why, you know,
you and I make the same distinction.
I've made a distinction for years and
years between the Liberals and the left.
If the left continues
to conquer the liberals,
I think that it's gonna be a rough
time ahead and we better have these
alternative methods of distribution
are we're screwed at that point.
All right, so let's
finish with this then. Um,
when I was on canvas and show a week
or two ago, I said to her, you know,
I see something, it's so obvious
to me that if you care about ideas,
if you want to live in a tolerant,
pluralistic society, all of those things,
it's very obvious. The center, right
basically is where is where that's at. It,
it just is.
Do you think there is room for Pete for
the center writes a conservatives tab a
little more openness when
it comes to like, you know,
we've had the abortion
discussion tied to I'm,
I mean I'm really struggling with it
and the further that the left goes on,
eight month abortions and and all of that
and post life abortions and cool post
life abortion,
then this crazy stuff.
It's making my position incredibly
difficult and I think a lot of,
I think a lot of decent liberals
are struggling with this. How,
what do you think the right should do?
If you guys want to be a little more
opening, a little more welcoming,
let's say for people that are,
or seeing where tolerance
actually lives right now,
what do you think you can do on,
on issues like that?
Cause I'm not saying that
the right has to be told,
the only choice partier or a pro choice
set of ideas or anything like that.
But what, what do you
think is, is your job?
Well, I mean one of the, that is one,
maybe the only issue that I can think
of where the right generally and I think
correctly believes in government
compulsion, meaning that the,
the basic thesis of the right is that
when a life is threatened than the
government has a right to step in.
And this is a life that is threatened,
the government has rights to step in.
And so this I'm not sure as a bridgeable
gap, what I mean by that is that the,
the right can continue to make the case,
uh,
the right to continue to make the case.
I'm going to case I agree with. Um, but I,
I can't,
I'm not libertarian on this issue because
I don't think it's a libertarian issue.
So here there's a national
seen that the right has to modify its
position. I actually don't mean that.
What I mean is just that for the things
that might be the differences if you
were, if you were just looking to
collect x lefties right now, right.
But here's the toddler group
like w how do you welcome,
well, I mean here's, here's where I was
cause I think they're afraid. I think
that I think most of them have PTSD.
I realize this is what I really did.
I mean the,
the first place to start is why don't
we start with the stuff where we agree
because the truth is that the
checks and balances of the system,
just on a practical level,
the checks and balances of the system are
not going to allow for full protection
of life anytime soon.
The,
the sort of attempts that have been made
on the right to move in a more pro life
direction have been incremental
at best. And so if it, listen,
if that's the issue that's going to,
you know,
bar you from joining the
right than the CSU should,
it's going to borrow from joining the
writers. Not much I can do about that.
But you know,
we're w I'm happy to welcome anybody to
the conversation and you don't have to
agree with me on abortion to be part
of the conversation. Like, I, we,
you and I don't agree on this and we,
we have this conversation on a pretty
routine basis. I do it all the time. So,
you know, I, I don't think
that there's in it, as I say,
there are certain issues where
the right is not going to move.
And frankly I don't think
the right should move.
This is one of those the only issues.
Um, but can I make a bold prediction?
Sure. 30 years from now we're going
to be sitting here doing this,
hopefully in that bigger girl in Texas
probably may well have moved me on the,
uh, on the abortion issue and I think
I may have moved you oncoming to an
anniversary party. W what do you think
about that? I think there's possibility.
I mean, I, I'd have to, I'd have
to think about that again. The,
the issue as you know, you
know, not to get back. Well
Trod territory. Uh, you know,
I think it would be unlikely
that you'd moved me, but I,
I can never rule out the possibility
being moved on anything. Obviously. Um,
and again, this is, this
comes back down to, you know,
the difference between
approving of activity and
approving of, of human beings.
And they, yeah, I wouldn't, if you
invited me to a party on Friday night,
I also wouldn't go right.
I mean like definitely not a Shabbat.
A I Shabaka anniversary I think
probably is. Yeah. Yeah. Uh,
Sunday afternoon,
a Sunday afternoon gayish anniversary.
Like, or, or maybe just, it's not about,
you sound like a fricking barbecue dude.
Like does everything have to be going
with the party's not going to be gay.
It's just, yeah, we'll
have a barbecue. Okay.
Just be gay is going to happen there
when I wasn't where he was going to turn
into an orgy back there
or something like that.
So I wasn't worried you're going to
bring out the village people or something
like that. We'll have parties just to
say, well wait, why, what does that,
that's crazy. Yeah, no, I was,
I was pretty well aware of
that, in fact. And in fact,
as I've said a thousand times, you
happy to go out to dinner? My wife,
your husband, happy to go out to
dinner and do any of that stuff.
As long as it's not like,
you know, Rah Rah, here's the
thing you think is in full,
join me in celebrating it.
But again, that appeals,
that applies to a wide variety of
settings that it, I mean, listen,
it's harder on it. It's harder on
members of my family than anybody else.
Like I've said before,
I wouldn't attended intermarriage
Ratika jewelries and Andrea,
I want to tend intermarriage. Yeah. So
this is exactly the same issue. Shapiro,
they're giving me the signal
that you [inaudible] out.
I feel like we just had a radio show
doing like five minutes. Yeah, exactly.
All right. That's Ben Shapiro daily
wire at Ben Shapiro on Twitter.
The book is the right side of history.
Is it number one on Amazon right now? Uh,
well it was, it was number one on the New
York Times list in his first week. Nice.
And so we knocked off Michelle Obama for
all week and then she took revenge and,
and knock us back to number three.
But, but for a week, for a week.
That's the battle of the left and the
right. That's data right there. All right.
That's it.
Thanks everybody.